écoutez moi tout le monde si vous faites
trop de bruit je vais vous renvoyer dans
la salle de classe entendu certaines
personnes n'aiment pas le cirque
nous devons éveiller l'intérêt pour le
cirque chez les adultes et les enfants
pour les inciter à venir et à apprendre
[Musique]
et bien l'entrée d'une main et rattraper
avec l'autre
[Musique]
je joue à quoi joue est important pour
un an il ya eu un bombardement récemment
tout le monde a été tuée femmes
vieillards et enfants
tout a été détruit il ya un monde à
l'extérieur
il en existe un autre ici à l'intérieur
de ses murs
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 25 février de nouveaux cas
de coronavirus en france selon le
ministère de la santé l'épidémie s'étend
en europe où plus d'une trentaine de
pays sont désormais concernés par des
patients infectés pour l'om et ce moment
n'est simplement pas prêt face à cette
épidémie
le spectre du 49 3 se rapproche edouard
philippe laisse la porte ouverte à cette
possibilité afin de faire adopter son
vote le projet de réforme des retraites
le premier ministre qui demandait un peu
plus tôt aux députés la république en
marge de tenir encore face à
l'obstruction de l'opposition le retour
à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution nécessite le feu vert du
conseil des ministres le président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
s'est lui l'engagement pour la cause
palestinienne de l'ancien président de
l'egypte hosni moubarak est décédé
aujourd'hui au caire à l'âge de 91 ans
celui qui a présidé le pays sans partage
pendant près de trois décennies avait dû
quitter le pouvoir à la suite de la
révolution égyptienne en 2012 chassé par
le peuple
deuxième jour à londres du procès de
julian assange la justice britannique
examine depuis hier la demande
américaine d'extradition du fondateur de
wikileaks sa défense qui aujourd'hui
s'est plaint du traitement qui lui est
infligé washington accuse le lanceur
dallaire d'espionnage
il risque jusqu'à 175 ans de prison
[Musique]
la france contre désormais deux nouveaux
cas confirmés de coronavirus l'épidémie
se propage en europe
des cas confirmés ont été recensés en
suisse en espagne croatie et en autriche
l'épidémie a fait 11 morts désormais
dans le nord de l'italie 322 personnes
sont contaminées dans le pays y compris
en toscane en ligurie et en sicile
malgré tout le ministre français de la
santé olivier verront réaffirme sa
volonté de ne pas fermer les frontières
à l'heure actuelle nous souhaitons être
extrêmement clair sur le fait qu'il n'y
a pas lieu de fermer les frontières
entre nos pays ce serait disproportionné
et efi et inefficace à ce stade nous
souhaitons également dire qu'il n'ya pas
lieu d'annuler a priori les grands
événements publics qu'ils soient nature
sportive ou culturelle mais nous nous
accordons la possibilité au cas par cas
de regarder chaque situation en fonction
de l'évaluation que nous aurons de la
part des autorités scientifiques et
sanitaires notamment
et si la fermeture des frontières n'est
pas d'actualité paris invite les
français à reporter leur voyage vers les
zones contaminées d'italie alors comment
on réagit style à la propagation de
l'épidémie écouter ces quelques
réactions c'est peu plus grave qu'une
grippe
bon voilà il ya plein d'épidémie donc
c'est pas plus on en parle plus mais
c'est pas beaucoup plus grave que le
pense à l'heure actuelle pour l'instant
mon avis il faut pas non plus
voilà l'armé tout le monde et puis faut
prendre des précautions faut être
vigilant mais de la fermer les
frontières non je pense pas qu'il faut
qu'il faille faire ce à quoi mon avis
c'est une bonne décision qu'il a prise
pour l'instant la situation actuelle
dont l'état du lieu de la maladie du
virus
je pense que oui il faut fermer cette
frontière qui t'a pas fermer totalement
mais de mettre des contrôles médicaux
des prises de température et surtout
pendant 14 jours arrêter tous
déplacements en france et puis voilà on
en parle on en parle on en parle on fout
du sytral songeant on leur fait peur
alors que finalement rien il ya d'autres
choses qui tue beaucoup plus que le
coronavirus quand on voit des envois
certains sondages où on dit que voilà
c'est 0,2 pour cent des gens qui meurent
à côté d'une grippe ou c'est beaucoup
plus que ça pour quoi [ __ ] la trouille
aux gens l organisation mondiale de la
santé juge très préoccupante cette
augmentation soudaine de nouveaux cas et
ce malgré un déclin en chine tout de
même nous est partie l'épidémie mais
carnon son effet 71 décès
supplémentaires soit le chiffre
quotidien le plus bas depuis plus de
deux semaines au total dans le monde
c'est donc une trentaine de pays qui
sont touchés par le virus quatre
nouveaux territoires du moyen-orient ont
rejoint la liste hier les personnes
concernées revenaient de l'iran qui
enregistre officiellement et 15 décès le
vice ministre iranien de la santé a lui
aussi été testé positif le récit de
françois tisci et beach sur ces images
lors d'un point presse sur le
coronavirus le vice-ministre de la santé
iranien iraj archi transpirant se frotte
le front est tous à plusieurs reprises
quelques heures plus tard
l'information est confirmée il est bien
porteur du virus
je voulais vous informer que je suis
positif pour le cours aux navires us
j'ai eu de la fièvre y hier mon texte
initial s'est avéré positif tard dans la
soirée
je me suis isolé dans un endroit depuis
hier soir
soyez assurés que nous vaincrons le
coronavirus soyez certains que nous le
ferons j'y crois de tout mon coeur
prenez soin de vous ce virus est un
virus démocratique
il ne fait pas de distinction entre les
riches et les pauvres ou autres
fonctionnaires et nos fonctionnaires
tout le monde peut la voir lors de cette
conférence ira jarir chier le porte
parole du gouvernement iranien avait
démenti l'affirmation d'un député
selon laquelle 50 personnes auraient
perdu la vie des suites de l'épidémie
dans la ville sainte de qom
d'où le virus est partie en iran le
gouvernement promet la transparence mais
les iraniens reste inquiet j'ai vraiment
peur il n'y a pas de masque dans les
pharmacies le gouvernement devrait
distribuer des masques gratuitement aux
gens s'ils veulent le contenir
nous avons très peur le monde entier
touchées et cela se propage la
télévision d'état nous donne des
statistiques mais quand nous allons à
l'hôpital nous voyons que c'est
différent
le nombre de décès bien plus élevé alors
que le président iranien annonce mardi
que l'iran surmonterait l'épidémie un
membre du parlement vient d'annoncer sur
twitter être également infectée par le
virus
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vincent maréchal professeur à la
sorbonne universités science spécialiste
en virologie
bonsoir professeur maréchal merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france parce qu'évidemment on a
beaucoup de questions à vous poser
tout d'abord ces deux cas confirmé dans
notre pays qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
dit aux français il faut les rassurer au
contraire est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter
je pense que le fait qu'on soit en
mesure de détecter avec une telle
efficacité des cas doit être pris comme
un message d' alerte il ya quelque chose
qui se passe et je crois qu on en est
tous conscient maintenant puis presque
qu'un mois et demi mais le message
positif c'est qu'on a les outils on à
l'infrastructure on a les compétences
dans nos hôpitaux on a les compétences
dans les laboratoires pour effectuer
très rapidement un diagnostic de
certitude ce qui veut dire que très
rapidement contrairement peut-être à
d'autres pays dans le monde ont été en
mesure d'identifier les cas de les
isoler de prendre des mesures qui évite
la propagation du virus dont je crois
qu'on est vraiment dans une phase
aujourd'hui où les outils où le maillage
épidémiologique qu'on a le maillage de
surveillance est tellement efficace
effectivement que pour l'instant détecte
les cas isolé les deux cas j'ai pas le
temps de me renseigner en détail sur la
nature des deux cas mais de toute
évidence viennent de régions dans
lesquelles on a des foyers infectieux
c'est pas des cas très étonnant alors
j'ai entendu parler d'un cas qui datent
de lombardie dont une patiente qui
viendrait de chine qu'elles sont situées
à paris et or de verm effectivement des
patientes viennent de judo ce ne sont
pas des cas atypique dans la dans la lah
dans l'identification fédéral à qui son
piano et on exactement viennent de
régions concertant on sait qui a des
problèmes ce que vous nous dites pour
bien comprendre le message c'est que
voilà l'épidémie peut arriver elle
arrive d'ailleurs dès mi mai
on est paré en france on est prêt à
l'affronter ces salles en jeu ce que je
dis c'est que ça c'est un constat qu'on
fait dans plusieurs pays l'information
scientifique a circulé relativement
rapidement alors on peut toujours
discuter sur le retard qui a eus en
chine à faire part de la situation
il ya une excellente coopération à
l'échelle internationale ça faut que les
gens en aient conscience c'est à dire
que les chercheurs les médecins ne sont
pas isolés dans les différents pays à
une circulation et un partage de
l'information scientifique qui est fait
de façon très très très efficaces ce qui
a permis à un très rapidement très
transparent ça c'est vraiment une
condition essentielle
ce qui a permis très rapidement de
développer des tests pour détecter de
façon spécifique les gens qui sont
infectés ce qui veut dire très
rapidement qu'on peut les isoler et donc
ça c'est important lorsqu'on voit
également en france et qu on a eu des
crises précédemment il ya eu la grippe
aviaire pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
ya eu la grippe h1n1
on a eu ailleurs dans le monde les
épidémies 10 k et c'est donc on a on est
dans des situations dans lesquelles on
sait que ce risque infectieux existe on
sait que ces maladies qu'on appelle des
maladies émergentes risquent de revenir
avec une fréquence qui est qui n'est pas
négligeable
on parle de maladies qui pourraient
revenir tous les deux trois ans on est
prévenu on a donc des plans de gestion
sanitaire qui sont relativement efficace
on voit fonctionne relativement bien
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a aussi une
mise en place d'un réseau dans les
hôpitaux qui est qui et prépositionné
qui est peut se développer en fonction
de l'évolution de l'épidémie dont je
pense qu'on est plutôt bien préparé je
suis plus inquiète pour des pays
aujourd'hui qui ne déclaraient pas de
calais en attendant si on vous dit on
est bien préparé
on entend beaucoup il ya conflit social
évidemment en france que vous n'ignorez
pas les urgences qui manquent de lits
est ce qu'on aurait le cas échéant
suffisamment de lits notamment en
réanimation parce qu'on a vu que c'était
un petit peu le problème de cette
maladie dans un second temps en tout cas
quand on arrive et je pense qu'il faut
pas projeter la situation chinoise le
nombre de cas observés en chine à ce qui
se passe en france aujourd'hui dans une
situation vous voyez on en est à
quelques cas qu'on détecte qu'on isole
immédiatement donc je ne suis pas
spécialiste de la question et ça je
pense que c'est une question à poser
plutôt de la santé ou collègues qui gère
les hôpitaux il ya un message d alerte
je pense qu'il faut aussi répété que les
médecins sont excessivement sensibilisés
à la question que les personnels
soignants sensibilisés à la question que
la communication vous faites
journalistes médias sur cette question
là est essentiel je crois qu'il s'agit
pas d'affoler les gens mais plutôt de
faire comprendre que si on communique
beaucoup c'est aussi pour que les gens
soient sensibilisés à cette question
prennent les mesures préventives
vous revenez on l'a dit bricout à vous
revenez d'une zone à risque est bien
plutôt que d'aller prendre le métro si
vous avez un doute vous restez à la
maison vous mettez en quarantaine ou là
des messages sont passés notamment pour
les gens revenant de l'italie dans les
zones à risque on passe la période
d'incubation et en cas de doute en cas
d'apparition de signes cliniques ont
fait le 15 et on a déjà en phase qui
vous répondre alors des questions
précises sait combien la période
d'incubation ce temps par les 14 où on a
refait surface et 27 jours alors oui
alors il ya ya
il y as on affine les données au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution de la maladie
on a les données chinoises ont été les
premières collecter on a des collègues
qui travaillent un peu partout dans le
monde sur cette question là donc les
chiffres sa fille donc il faut pas
s'étonner à ce que l'on revoit au fil de
l'eau à sare compte deux notions
aujourd'hui ce qui a l'air d'être
globalement acceptée c'est que
l'incubation est de l'ordre de 14 jours
et effectivement il ya un cas qui a été
d'écrire en chine je crois d'un patient
donc il est vraisemblable ou en tout cas
il est affirmé qu'il aurait été infecté
qu'il aurait déclenché et signe 27 jours
plus tard il est possible effectivement
qui est une extension de l'incubation
mais à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on sait que
c'est que 14 jours c'est quand même les
chiffres qu'on observe le plus
fréquemment on entendait dire le chef de
l' oms en chine hier la le monde n'est
pas prêt pourquoi cette maladie est elle
aussi peur c'est parce qu'on ne la
connais pas assez bien alors il ya
plusieurs choses d'abord c'est une
maladie qui est baky qui frappe
l'imaginaire c'est comme une maladie est
associé à une mortalité qui qui moindre
que celle du strass qu'on a connue en
2003 qui était de l'ordre de 10 % de
mortalité là on est à 2 %
pour mémoire une grippe hivernale c'est
0 1% dans ses vingt fois plus mortelle
que la grippe hivernale qu'on connaît
bien
il ya ce caractère là il ya la vitesse
de dissémination qui quoi qu'on en dise
est assez spectaculaire et ça c'est lié
à ces virus qui sont transmis par voie
aérienne par voie respiratoire
donc on a un tableau qui est un tableau
qui inquiète avec une maladie qui
circule très très vite et ça je crois
que c'est le constat aussi d'un monde
dans lequel les communications sont très
ouvertes et donc les marchandises
circulent les personnes circulent les
pathogènes et lady recul les virus
circulent également
est-ce que vous pensez que l'épidémie
risque vraiment d'augmenter se
transformer en pandémie il faudrait
activé ce plan pandémie là aussi à une
je crois qu'il faut il faut dire les
choses clairement la notion de pandémie
c'est une épidémie qu'on décrète
d'ampleur d'amplitude mondial donc un
des critères qui sont d'ailleurs pas
forcément partagé par tous pour dire
qu'à partir d'une épidémie qui se
déclare sur plusieurs continents on est
on est à une échelle pandémie ce qu'il
faut que les gens comprennent également
c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on passe
d'un stade l'épidémie qui un stade
pandémique qui ne surent épidémiologique
qu'on a une gravité des infections qui
est plus importante le virus sont là on
est en train de parler d'un virus car
sans doute peu évolué ça surprend mais
c'est comme ça c'est un gosse qui a peu
évolué et qui ne gagne pas non plus en
pathogénicité c'est juste extension de
la pathologie qui passe d'une zone
régionale ou à de plusieurs zones
régionales à une zone beaucoup plus
élargie à quoi doit-on s'attendre
il y aura un public on dit rôle avec la
chaleur ça va tendre à disparaître
est ce que ce sont là des bruits de
couloirs du pouvoir c'est parce qu'on
cherche des références dans les virus
qu'on l'a déjà dans nos dans nos tiroirs
on fréquente le virus qui ressemble le
plus et vous voyez bien dans l'actualité
auxquels on fait le plus référence à
virus grippal orsec le virus grippal
circule dans les pays au moment des
périodes humides et période froide et on
sait qu effectivement balle à la période
grippale s'arrête au printemps et
reprend l'année d'après pendant l'hiver
et donc effectivement on se dit bah le
modèle grippe a n'est peut-être pas si
loin que ça du modèle coronavirus parce
que coronavirus partagent un certain
nombre de propriétés mais n'est pas
identique du tout virus de la grippe un
partage peut-être des propriétés
communes donc on peut faire ce type de
projection
on n'est pas sûr aujourd'hui il faut
évaluer la résistance du virus aux
conditions environnementales à la
sécheresse à la chaleur et tout ça c'est
bien après l'énoncé des données qu'on
aura un jour ou l'autre ces données
qu'on est en train de laisser d'acquérir
dans les laboratoires qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent faire qu'on
on va s'en sortir vaccin est en cours on
imagine d'élaboration les recherches en
tout cas sont des recherches là encore
une fois faut voir qu'on est allé très
très vite falala le monde scientifique
et le monde médical ont réagi très très
vite
on est sur une épidémie quand même qui
démarre en décembre janvier
dès janvier on isole le virus donc ce
qui était l'une des étapes essentielles
pour construire un test diagnostique à
l'institut pasteur dont ils ont tant
fait très efficacement et très
rapidement pu isoler le virus construire
un tel diagnostic et le virus
l'obtention du virus est une étape
préalable à tester dans les molécules
qu'on a dans nos laboratoires dans
l'informatique et des molécules
antivirales donc dès qu'on peut cultiver
le virus en laboratoire ou peu commencé
à cribler des molécules et à voir si on
a pas déjà quelque chose et puis
l'obtention du virus était une étape
très importante également pour procéder
à la fabrication d'un vaccin
néanmoins un vaccin est en période où
tout va bien il ya une vague en france
en particulier contre les vaccins on
s'inquiète d'une injection d'utilisation
des vaccins
un vaccin c'est quelque chose qu'on a
aussi testé où il faut s'assurer avant
de la ministre à grande échelle qui a
pas de risque sanitaire à l'aide à
administrer le vaccin donc il ya des
étapes à franchir
il faut tout un réseau industriel qui
soit structuré qui puisse produire
suffisamment de doses et ça aujourd'hui
on sait le faire pour la grippe par
exemple que chaque année on a un nouveau
vaccin pour le coronavirus tout système
là n'est pas encore en place mais il est
vraisemblable qu'on puisse le faire
alors donner des délais aujourd'hui
c'est pour moi c'est juste pas possible
je travaille pas sur le sujet il faudra
aller voir les spécialistes et les gens
dans leurs laboratoires
on espérait être un peu rassuré mais en
tout cas vous voyez dans les outils pour
le faire mais merci en tout cas pour
vous avez des données des explications
très claires même si moi qui combine
avec le professeur vincent maréchal
mercier aversion contre l'épidémie qui
fait souffler un vent de panique
jusqu'au marché boursier la bourse a
décroché hier soir notamment paris
londres et francfort les places
européennes ont clôturé sur des pertes
comprises entre 3 à plus de 5% à new
york le dow jones a connu hier sa pire
séance depuis plus de deux ans ce matin
la bourse de tokyo et les places
financières chinoises ont ouvert en
repli le cours du pétrole est également
plombée par les inquiétudes liées à ce
coronavirus
en france edouard philippe demande aux
députés de la majorité de tenir encore
face à l'obstruction de l'opposition sur
la réforme des retraites
le premier ministre l'a sûr si besoin il
prendra ses responsabilités en recourant
aux 49 3 en écoute
lorsqu'il faut prendre ses
responsabilités je le fais sans hésiter
et j'utilise tout la constitution rien
que la constitution mais bien toute la
constitution il appartient monsieur le
président à l'assemblée nationale
elle-même de faire vivre ce débat
si ce débat vie et qu'il permet
d'avancer dans de bonnes conditions tant
mieux c'est ce que je souhaite mais à
partir d'un certain moment il faut être
clair nous nous sommes engagés sur ce
système universel de retraite par
répartition et par point et l'engagement
du gouvernement le fait majoritaire
ça existe en attendant les débats se
poursuivent à l'assemblée pour protester
contre cette réforme une marge de 8
jours a été organisée elle est arrivée
aujourd'hui à paris les membres devaient
société civile des syndicats des élus la
france insoumise également ont quitté
laval en mayenne lundi dernier et
protestataires qui dénoncent le possible
recours aux 49 3 on écoute le patron
d'air france à clermont il vaut mieux
qu'ils réfléchissent à ce qu'ils font
parce que moi je reçois beaucoup de
messages
je n'imaginais pas que ça
l'impact pareil sur la sensibilité du
public beaucoup de gens sont compris
qu'il y avait le risque du 49-3 il ya
déjà des consignes de rassemblement
autour de l'assemblée si le 49 3 et
décidez donc je pense qu'il ya où il ya
de l'émotion dans le pays et qu'ils
doivent le savoir auprès de maquereaux
et d'edouard philippe ils doivent se
demander alors ce matin nous a fait un
petit numéro à la conférence des
présidents le président de l'assemblée
nous a dit attacher de prévoir votre
procuration pour les deux tours des
élections municipales parce que vous
serez dans l'hémicycle chassant la ruse
et conséquents seront pas de cette
réforme des retraites controversé les
cotes de popularité des manuels macro et
d'edouard philippe sont en baisse celle
du président de la république chute de
trois points et celle de son premier
ministre est en légère baisse -1 selon
un sondage aux hawks à cgi publié mardi
un français sur trois considère qu
emmanuel macron est un bon président
contre 66 % d'un avis contraire à l'avis
contraire qu'il progresse donc de plus
de 2 fois et pour en parler nous sommes
avec francis choisel historien de la
constitution bonsoir francis choisel à
merci d'être avec nous avec vous on va
parler de ce fameux 49,3 une arme liste
et yves nucléaire comme on la surnomme
parfois d'ailleurs c'est un surnom qui
lui est bien approprié selon vous c'est
une arme qui n'est pas forcément du
clair mais je trouve que c'est surtout
une arme qui n'est pas adaptée à la
situation
ou du moins pas adaptée à celle ci oui
dans la situation actuelle c'est à dire
que on nous dit qu'il ya trop
d'amendements que le débat va être trop
long il faut raccourcir le débat mais le
49-3 n'est pas né n'a jamais été prévu
pour raccourcir un débat il a été prévu
pour empêcher pour supprimer un vote
donc je ne comprends pas bien si je
comprends un peu mais je veux dire on ne
comprend pas bien pourquoi il ya tout ce
débat autour de 49 3 pourquoi on brandit
la menace du 49-3 pour raccourcir des
débats alors que ça n'est pas son objet
et qu'il y à un autre article le 44 3
qui s'appelle le vote bloqué
qui lui permettrait de voter mais de
raccourcir les débats
effectivement c'est intéressant vous
êtes en train de nous dire que
finalement le 49 3 et détourné de son
utilisation de sa vocation première
ça pourrait être ça détourne est vite
détourné ce sera une critique
moi je dirais plutôt que c'est comme
prendre une canne à pêche pour aller à
la chasse ou prendre une fusée pour
aller à la pêche
si on réussit à s'en servir pour pêcher
pour chasser en n'ayant pas le bon outil
pourquoi pas au passé mais mais ça n'est
pas le mot ce que ce que ce que je
voulais dire c'est que il faut chercher
pourquoi on utilise cet outil là plutôt
que l'autre l'autre le vote bloqué les
simples c'est le gouvernement peut
décider de faire voter sur son texte et
qu'il n'y ait plus d'amendements et la
constitution dit même tout ou partie du
texte
c'est à dire que demain matin d'hier je
mets en oeuvre le 44 3
plus de discussion vote et pourquoi ne
le ferait-il pas dans ce cas parce qu'il
a peut-être un problème de vote
peut-être parce que il a envie d'agiter
tous les médias vous moi autour du 49 3
est-ce qu'en l'espèce c'est un scénario
quand même qui vous semble inéluctable
on est dans une situation c'est inédite
des milliers et des milliers et des
milliers d'amendements plus de 40000
déposé essentiellement par la france 1-1
soumises
effectivement ce qu'ils ont buts ils le
disent eux-mêmes de bloquer ces débats
qu'est ce qui reste comme alternative
finalement au gouvernement en l'espèce
c'est ce que je vous dise c'est
d'utiliser un autre article le cas le
quart d'heure trop peu importe son
numéro d'ailleurs c'est à dire le vote
bloqué
vous disiez comme tout le monde il ya
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup d'
obstruction d'ailleurs l'obstruction ne
me choque pas plus que l'utilisation
éventuelle du 49-3 ou de 44,3
l'obstruction et j'allais dire est
vieille comme le monde je caricature un
peu mais la première fois que
l'obstruction été utilisés c'est ce sont
les irlandais au parlement britannique
qui ont décidé alors non pas de mettre
des tonnes d'amendements mais de faire
des discours fleuves et ils ont même
pris la bible puis lisez la bible et ils
ont réussi comme ça une fois à faire
durer 26 heures une serre une séance
donc l'objectif c'est l'obstruction
alors que l'obstruction qu'est ce que
ces basses et les gilets jaunes ont
bloqué les carrefours les la cgt à
bloquer les transports et ben allal un
france insoumise bloc le parlement et ce
qu'ils essayent c'est d'obtenir un
résultat politique par ce blocage que
alors j'ai dit grève c'est que c'est
l'équivalent d'une rave c'est
l'équivalent d'une guérilla en anglais
on peut on distribue sting ses dires
flibuste cessé de la guérilla les
irlandais en tout cas on réussit à faire
à obtenir dans les années 1870 1880
ils ont réussi à obtenir que leur cause
soit écoutée par le board parlement
britannique donc c'est parfois un bon
calcul
on peut se scandaliser qu'il n'y a pas
de discussions mais je reviens si si on
veut supprimer les amendements le
gouvernement ne peut alors s'il est
utilisé ce que ça serait justement
vraiment la fin des débats
en l'espèce oui ce serait là ce serait
la fin des débats mais ce sera surtout
la fin du vote
c'est à dire que le preuve le principe
du 49 3 c'est que l'origine du 49 3 en
1958 c'était d'éviter la valse des
ministères parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
y avait un texte
quand ils étaient rejetés le ministère
le gouvernement se croyait obligé de
démissionner donc on le 43 son objectif
cessé de dire au député attendait c'est
un texte important est ce que
franchement vous voulez renverser
gouvernement sur ce sujet là qui est un
sujet mineur et donc on leur dit voilà
si si vous ne déposez pas de motion de
censure
le texte passe alors vous voyez c'est
pour empêcher que les gouvernements
tombent partout presque par hasard des
fois parce qu'un texte mineurs et
renverser la sépaq l'ex ministre
justement c'est une utilisation année
assez inédite on sait que monsieur
regard l'avait utilisé à de nombreuses
reprises je crois 28 fois mais c'était
différent il avait une majorité
extrêmement fébrile françois hollande
évidemment enfin d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'autres gouvernements l'ont utilisé
mais souvent pour calmer une majorité
turbulente là c'est effectivement oui
localement différence et se produit
habituellement qu'il est destinée non
pas à museler l'opposition
parce qu'on peut avoir le 49-3 la preuve
avec des discussions avant ça ne
raccourcit pas la discussion s'est
empêché vonn je le répète ça n'aide
jamais 10 euros qu'une chaîne excepté ce
mardi sur la vôtre je le répète c'est
c'est le vote qui est supprimé ça n'est
pas là ce n'est pas la discussion est
donc le du point de vue de la majorité
ça peut arranger aussi la majorité c'est
à dire vous avez des députés qui
retournent dans les circonscriptions qui
seront disputés faut que vous votiez
faut pas que vous votiez
et donc quand tu es quand ils 49,3 n'ont
pas voté ils ont simplement à ne pas
censurer le gouvernement
et donc ils peuvent retourner vers leurs
électeurs les hommes at il dit vous avez
votre non j'ai pas voté
j'ai simplement refusé de renverser le
gouvernement et donc la suppression du
vote
elle n'est pas lié je pense à la crainte
du gouvernement de ne pas faire passer
le texte sa majorité suffisamment large
mais peut-être qu'il considère que ça
ferait désordre
s'il y avait un certain nombre de gens
que tous les médias appellerait des
frondeurs comme du temps de françois
hollande alors qu'il y en a dix qui en
écrit un scanner 20 qui ont des 50
ça ferait désordre là on ne les verra
pas on ne les verra pas parce que dans
le vote du 49-3 ne votent que alors
d'abord il faut que l'hymne censure
d'une motion de censure qu'ils soient
déposées et on ne comptabilise que le
nombre de ceux qui votent la censure
tous les autres tous les autres ils
n'ont pas voté contre la censure
il s'est dit que l'on d'une abstention
ils n'ont rien fait c'est cdu course
pilate en fait
voyez donc ça peut allonger la majorité
ça peut engendrer un parce qu'il
s'agissait pour les jeux je dis les
choses de façon un peu méchante mais des
gens qui ont des quatre conscience
qui dit je ne veux pas en toute
conscience voter cela et vous demande
pas de nouveautés vous demande pas de
voter on devrait tout simplement de ne
pas renverser le gouvernement
on a des grands prix mercier en tout cas
francis loisel d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france historien de la
constitution dans quelques instants
elle était avec nous nous reviendrons
sur le décès de l'ancien président
égyptien hosni moubarak a régné sur le
pays pendant 30 ans avant d'être chassé
par le peuple et puis direction le
royaume uni au deuxième jour du procès
en extradition du lanceur dallaire de
julian assange
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro donc
et puis du sud qui n'ont pas encore
retrouvé leur niveau de richesse d'avant
la crise vous avez la grèce et aussi
lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on a pu
avoir au niveau de l'eau de la zone euro
n'a pas réussi à sortir de la crise
c'est à dire qu'on vous parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous les pays avaient notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré de 350 je ne sais
pas qui est la locomotive de l'europe en
tout cas ne croyez pas que ce soit la
france
[Musique]
oui c'est comme si j'étais passé à une
autre époque les cadets un peu de nerf
c'est quoi ce chaos
je suis plus une personne de la terre au
four et aujourd'hui j'ai quitté la
maison pour aller en mer c'est moi le
maître du perroquet bordel
[Musique]
regardez c'est pas croyable
une conquête je ne pensais pas être
aussi forte avant même une barque sur
une rivière
j'aurais eu peur de me noyer mais
maintenant je m'en fiche
on va pas couler avec ce bateau enfin si
dieu le veut
[Musique]
et
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france la mort de l'ancien président
égyptien hosni moubarak
l décédé au caire à l'âge de 91 ans une
annonce faite par sa famille hosni
moubarak avait dirigé l'egypte pendant
près de trois décennies il a été chassé
du pouvoir en 2011 par la foule place
tahrir au cours de la révolution
égyptienne lâché par l'armée il avait
été condamné à la prison à perpétuité en
juin 2012 pour sa responsabilité dans
l'assassinât de quelques 850
manifestants
mais il a finalement été libéré en mars
2010 est très affaibli l'ancien chef de
l'état se trouvait depuis plusieurs
années à l'hôpital militaire gala à du
caire retour en images sur son parcours
[Musique]
et
et nous
[Musique]
et
mais les hommages avec semi notamment du
premier ministre palestinien mahmoud
abbas qui salue son engagement pour la
cause palestinienne
une émotion partagée par le premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
qui salue un ami écouter au nom des
citoyens d'israël et au nom du
gouvernement israélien je voudrais
exprimer mon profond regret pour la
disparition du président hosni moubarak
le président moubarak
mon ami personnel était un leader qui a
conduit son peuple à la paix et à la
sécurité à la paix avec israël je les ai
rencontrés plusieurs fois et j'ai été
impressionné par son engagement et nous
continuerons à suivre cette voie commune
je tiens à adresser mes condoléances au
président el sissi à la famille moubarak
et au peuple égyptien est la population
divisée jusqu'à présent revient avec un
peu d'amertume sur l'image qu'elle garde
de l'ancien chef de l'état égyptien
peut-être que nous les générations des
années soixante dix et quatre vingts
avons grandi avec cet homme que nous
considérons comme un père il a été au
pouvoir pendant plus de trente ans qu'il
repose en paix c'était un homme
respectable et c'est ce que nous avons
vu dans les médias mais ce n'est pas à
nous de juger sa personnalité
nous avons vécu longtemps sous son règne
ça n'a pas été court comme pour d'autres
présidents et franchement les gens se
sentent mal pour lui
ma famille se sent mal nous lui
souhaitons miséricorde et pardon qu'il
repose en paix c'était un homme
respectable et nous avons été témoin de
beaucoup de bonnes choses en son temps
mais il a subi beaucoup d'injustices
dans ce pays
c'était une grande injustice mais
qu'allons nous dire qu'il repose en paix
et pour en parler nous sommes avec ahmad
youssef écrivain journaliste directeur
exécutif du centre du moyen-orient à
paris bonsoir ahmad youssef merci d'être
avec nous reçoit que retiendra-t-on que
retiendrez-vous de ce fonds moubarak
je suis je fais confiance aux sentiments
du peuple égyptien vous avez vu
l'érection et ses talons qui très
respecté en egypte on le considère comme
un père moi personnellement j'avais
quelques critiques et mme un trait sur
sa façon de gouverner le pays vers la
fin de son règne
mais si on regarde d'une façon un peu
plus large sur les trente ans donc de
son de son règne en egypte
on peut dire d'une façon juste et
objectif que c'était un bon président et
que là est la garantie à l'egypte une
stabilité de 30 ans dans une région
qu'on peut le savez qui est une région
qui ressemble beaucoup à un baril de
poudre et qu' il a réussi à garder le
traité de paix entre israéliens et
palestiniens
aider les israéliens et les palestiniens
et d un peu l'egypte elle-même pour se
relever économiquement et c'est donc ce
n'était pas au fond un quelqu'un de
mauvais on va revenir effectivement dans
certains détails de ce que vous nous
dites mais il n'y a pas beaucoup quand
même de grandes réactions c'est ce qui
frappe une forme d'indifférence mai mais
presque peu de réactions de deux chefs
d'état part peut-être les deux qu'on a
entendu on va y revenir
il ya une forme d'indifférence vous êtes
d'accord avec ça et comment vous
l'expliquez c'est un peu tôt pour dire
une différence parce que donc nous a
quittés cet après-midi en mais vous
savez comment c'est en général les
médias voilà il ya vriller les foules de
réactions sur les dépêches oui les gens
sont prudents parce que j'aime bien les
quartiers oui il est parti dans des
conditions particulières comme vous le
savez il est parti parce qu'il y avait
une révolution mais avec beaucoup de
courage elle a décidé de rester pas dans
le pays n'a pas fui et n'a pas réprimé
dans le sang
la révolution donc tranquillement il a
quitté le pouvoir et la laisser la place
à d'autres personnes mais je mens je
crois que c'est à l'histoire qu'il faut
laisser maintenant la parole et pour
juger un petit peu son action son oeuvre
et son patriotisme qui comme vient de le
voir un peu connu par les égyptiens
alors il ya effectivement quelque chose
qui frappe c'est qu'à la fois benyamin
nétanyahou qui est pas toujours connu
pour sa modération a salué un ami et
dans le même temps mahmoud abbas qui
salue quelqu'un qui a un vrai pour la
cause palestinienne
ils sont enfin d'accord sur quelque
chose c'est que c'est pas forcément 6,26
à émerger sur la personnalité et de
moubarak dont qui se sont donc mis tous
les deux d'accord je crois qu'ils ont
compris
mahmoud abbas le président abbas et le
premier ministre israélien que moubarak
était une soupape de sécurité dans la
région
hélas comme vous vous souvenez
certainement que les conférences de paix
qu'il a organisée à charm-el-cheikh
plusieurs conférences notamment la
présence de quelques chefs detat
français européens et américains donc il
a un vrai pendant 30 ans pour la
question pour la paix disant je vais pas
dire seulement la question palestinienne
peu mais pour la paix au moyen orient
c'était et il avait une vision si on
veut la paix au moyen orient
alors c'est vrai que on lui a reproché
parfois son rapprochement avec israël
dans les pays arabes tout de même à tous
les visages de blizzard a requis contre
le traité de paix aux comptes la paix
avec israël si vous allez dans les camps
des extrémistes c'est tout ça et bien
sûr je veux son pompon mais si vous
allez dans la rue arabe en général et
bien elles seront pas contre son action
pour la paix dans le maine orient alors
vous l'avez dit il est resté président
30 ans et plus que s'adapter et que
nécessaire qu'est ce qui lui a permis de
rester aussi longtemps au pouvoir
ce vers l'egypte un président c'est un
peu aussi un père de la nation je veux
passer d'un pharaon je n'aime pas ce mot
mais c'est presque ça c'est un président
c'est un père donc il se donne le
pouvoir de rester le peuple lui autorise
ça a battu du moment où il garantit au
peuple une bonne vie le une sécurité et
une prospérité et c'est à une sorte en
egypte de respect entre le peuple et la
fonction présidentielle
c'est pas lui même c'est pas moubarak lô
ni sa date ni dans celle c'est la
fonction présidentielle si un peu le
pharaon qui règne dans le pays il ya un
respect presque dans du jus d'airelles
religieux à vous avez de l'homme qui
dirige deux nations c'était le dernier
des pharaons d'egypte
c'est une bonne question je crois que
oui ça veut dire l'egypte jusque là être
gouvernée par trois présidents le
pharaon l'actuel président ce n'est pas
avare armes c'est quelqu'un qui essaie
de redresser le pays dans des conditions
terriblement difficile je crois quand
même l'actuelle présidente n'a pas envie
d'être un parent et que mais on peut le
dire que moubarak était le dernier
pharaon d'égypte est-ce que c'est
justement l'actuel président qui a
permis la libération de hosni moubarak
on rappelle qu'il était condamné à la
prison à vie
le président c'est la justice égyptienne
qui est donc qui a permis au président
défunt de sortir de sa prison pour des
raisons d'abord d'abord 202 il était
très malade
comment le sait très âgé et après bon on
n'a pas vraiment
critiqué le président soupçonneux onat
était personnelle son intégrité
personnelle il n'avait pas vraiment de
vraies critiques probablement la classe
que de mener sont sous sa présidence ou
sept ans de ses collaborateurs lui même
et ne se parlent de j -l vous parlais
tout à l'heure du peuple égyptien qui
respecte éminemment la fonction
présidentielle sauf que ce même peuple
en 2011 a dit stop
1 il a chassé hosni moubarak du pouvoir
pourquoi ce moment là il a été lâché
notamment par ses pairs et par l'armée
quelle je pense que la question est
beaucoup plus compliqué que cela il y
avait le projet de la succession du
président on avait beaucoup parlé à tort
de son fils
et après l'armée l'armée égyptienne est
là mais qui suis toujours la volonté du
peuple
quand l'armée a vu cole hawes donc ce 27
janvier 2011 que le peuple ne voulait
plus est bien l'armé imprimé sur la
partie pour le peuple égyptien mais on a
compris bien plus tard qu'il y avait
tout un complot qui venaient de
l'extérieur pour donc chassé moubarak m
des barbus à sa place vous voyez c'est
tout en place pour le moyen orient
fomenté par certains en occident on a vu
très bien qu'on a fait ça en irak on a
donc chassé ça donne forcément on a mis
des mollahs à sa place on a chassé
kadhafi
je défends pas les dictateurs la loi de
laruns mais à quoi sert de chasser un
président pour mettre à sa place dans
notre dictateur ou ans barbus ou à un
autre ont pu par exemple
alors c'est vrai que niveau barak vous
l'avais dit il ya vous parliez dictateur
dont il a été beaucoup près critiqué
notamment pour museler son opposition
emprisonner ses opposants vous vous le
défendez
là aussi où vous êtes quand même
d'accord avec ça écoutez les peurs de
moubarak
il faut pas oublier que les frères
musulmans avaient quand même 80 sièges
dans le parlement égyptien
donc c'était vraiment inédit dans
l'histoire de la confrérie en egypte
donc on peut pas dire que c'était un
dictateur
c'était une dictature molle de ces jeux
se dire c'était quelqu'un qui voulait
quand même le sait un espace à l'opinion
libre
l'expression d'opinions libre et papa la
façon d'autres dictatures
merci beaucoup ahmed youssef d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
nous parler donc d'hosni moubarak décédé
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 91 ans merci à
vous julien assange sera-t-il extradé
vers les états unis deuxième jour de
procès pour le fondateur de wikileaks
il comparaît depuis hier devant la
justice britannique
l'ombre doit décider de la suite ou non
à la demande américaine d'extradition du
lanceur dalet deweerdt australiens ont
fait le point à l'ombre avec un autre
reporter bassem chez vous
c'était une deuxième journée d'audience
pour julian assange dans ce procès hors
norme du lanceur d'alert qui a été placé
en détention depuis avril dernier après
avoir passé sept ans dans l'ambassade
équatorienne à londres deuxième jour
d'audience hier c'était les américains
qui ont plaidé ils ont revenu sûr c'est
que reprochés à julian assange à savoir
la publication 2010 de documents classés
top secret d'avoir mis en danger la vie
de témoins et la vie d'individus 18
chefs d'accusation contre lui
aujourd'hui c'était les avocats de
julian assange qui ont pu s'exprimer ils
sont revenus sur les conditions de
détention de julian assange sur ce que
reprochent les américains à junas
agissons contre cette extradition ils
ont dit qu'une extradition serait aller
à l'encontre de la liberté de la presse
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
julian assange vous propose d'écouter le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks ainsi que
le père de julian assange
nous sommes dans le contexte d'un empire
abusifs qui ré poste et qui veut se
venger sur une base politique pour faire
un exemple de julian assange pour faire
un exemple de lui pour effrayer les
autres journalistes qui veulent faire
leur travail en particulier ceux qui
s'intéressent aux problèmes de sécurité
tout ce procès auquel nous assistons
n'est compréhensible que si on prend en
compte la présence de forces obscures
qui tentent d'étouffer et de faire taire
ceux qui veulent mettre en lumière les
actions néfastes de cet empire
ce mal qui émane des services
persécuteurs s'est étendue sur dix ans
cela fait maintenant dix ans que julien
des prisonniers dix ans de détention
arbitraire de trahison et de tensions il
y à la torture psychologique aussi ces
deux faits ont été documentés par le
rapporteur des nations unies sur la
torture et le groupe de travail des
nations unies sur la détention
arbitraire
je ne comprends pas pourquoi julian
étant prises par john hester
absolument je pense que tout compte fait
c'est un procès politique est une perte
de temps pour le tribunal les avocats de
julian assange sont revenus sur les
allégations portées par les américains
sur ce dossier il ont déclaré que julian
assange ne faisait que son travail son
travail de journaliste et répondent à
ses négations et répondre favorablement
à une extradition vers les états unis ce
serait une régression dans la démocratie
une violation de la liberté de la presse
une violation de la liberté d'exercer le
métier de journaliste il ce revenu sur
les différents points développés par les
américains ils ont parlé de mensonges
ils ont ils également déclaré que
l'organe américain avait publié certains
documents qu'on reproche à wikileaks
d'avoir développé le l'audience
continuera bien sûr jusqu'à vendredi et
si la cour londonienne accès de cette
extradition
jonathan je pourrais en cours et jusqu'à
175 ans de réclusion et pour en parler
nous sommes avec guillaume ledit auteur
de dans la tête de julian assange chez
actes sud sortie donc en janvier 2020
bonsoir liés au lieu dit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
la défense de julian assange a parlé
aujourd'hui de traitement que subirait
leurs clients l'état de santé évidemment
inquiète on en parle souvent des
centaines de médecins et le rapporteur
de l'onu sur la torture avant même
donc donc que débute ce procès à quel
point ça peut compromettre la procédure
en cours et l'équitable écrite et de ce
procès selon vous alors il est clair que
sur pour les défenseurs de toute menace
en jeu son état psychologique et son
état physique et un est un véritable et
un véritable souci qui pourrait empêcher
de mener à bien sa défense il est quand
même entouré par une équipe de d2
défense extrêmement extrêmement précise
et extrêmement professionnel des avocats
internationaux qui viennent qui viennent
du monde entier et ses avocats sa
défense essaye de faire passer comme l'a
rappelé votre sujet l'idée selon
laquelle il s'agit on assiste
aujourd'hui à un procès politique
effectivement un procès politique qu'est
ce qui vous permet vous en tout cas de
dire ça est-ce que vous en avez le
sentiment en regardant le procès qui se
déroule ou tout simplement c'est un avis
personnel
à partir du moment où l'administration
trump a décidé de poursuivre le travail
de chasse aux lanceurs d'alerté mis en
place par l'administration obama et les
administrations précédentes
il apparaît assez clair que la volonté
du gouvernement des états unis et de
faire taire les lanceurs d'alerté dans
un premier temps et les journalistes
puis un deuxième temps ce qui est à
particulier avec avec ses audience
d'extradition c'est que julian assange
et s'il est extradé sera poursuivie aux
états unis au titre de l'espionage act
l'espionage act
comme son nom l'indiqué est un texte qui
date de 1917 et qui a pour vocation à
poursuivre les espions les ennemis des
etats-unis qui agissent à
l'international c'est la première fois
qu'un homme est poursuivi pour un
travail journalistique
au titre de cet espionnage actes car
julian assange comme vous le savez n'est
pas un simple lanceur d alerte c'est
également un homme qui a facilité donc
les des lanceurs d alerte les
publications document et qui a effectué
pour ce qui lui est reproché là dans le
cadre de ce procès un véritable le
travail journalistique puisqu'on parle d
des leaks qui date de 2010
voilà alors beaucoup d'observateurs
jugent des professionnels du droit que
la justice britannique est plutôt digne
de confiance qui est réputé pour son
intégrité est ce que tout de même même
s'il s'agit d'un procès c'est
certainement politique sur bien des
aspects ce que vous faites confiance à
cette justice anglaise
alors en tant qu' en tant que auteur
d'un ouvrage sans une nation j'ai pas
faire confiance à la justice britannique
j'espère que la justice britannique sera
ne pas céder à un certain nombre de
pressions notamment de l'administration
américaine un qui vont animer cette
semaine d'extradition puisqu'on sait que
un article de politico récemment a
révélé une des stratégies de la défense
qui est de de prouver que donald trump a
essayé d'intervenir lui même dans le
dans le le pr le procès en extradition
en notamment en voyant quelqu'un pour
dire que tous les ascenseurs ne sera pas
condamné à mort enfin bon tout cela est
en jeu évidemment il faut faire
confiance aux britanniques à la justice
britannique au processus juridique qui
va suivre son cours
toute cette semaine également deux
semaines au mois de mai puis ensuite il
ya des recours est le dernier recours
après la cour suprême britannique et la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme on
le sait les enjeux de cette affaire son
ultime de ce procès est ce que
clairement la liberté d'expression en
fait partie bien évidemment comme je
disais tout à l'heure quand on poursuit
un homme pour titre de l'espionage act 1
2917 je le rappelle une nouvelle fois
qui a notamment mené les époux rosenberg
à la chaise électrique pour des
motivations qui concerne ces pratiques
journalistiques
cela fait peser une énorme menace sur la
liberté d'expression sur la liberté de
la presse sur le droit d'informer et sur
le droit de savoir
à partir du moment où on a enclenché ce
processus là l'ensemble des journalistes
d'investigation de par le monde pourrait
être soumis à de telles poursuites et là
on
c'est un véritable problème au niveau
international alors vous l'avez dit
assange qui est accusée d'espionnage
qu'est-ce que des fois les selon vous
alors on va pas se lancer dans un grand
exposé parce que c'était appliqué en
quelques minutes
mais que peut dévoiler un an third
alerte sans franchir justement la limite
sans vous êtes accusé d'espionnage est
ce que justement la frontière n'est pas
difficile à connaître cette question
n'aurait pas à se la poser dans une
démocratie qui fonctionne normalement
aussi tous les documents classés secret
défense sont et il y en a de plus en
plus un document classé confidentiel
défense ou secret défense si à chaque
fois qu'on publie un de ces documents on
risque soit en france et qu'on une
convocation à la dgse ou à la
déchetterie soit aux états unis à des
poursuites judiciaires
il ya un véritable problème
à partir du moment où comme je voulais
massin wikileaks était censé être l'
agence de renseignement du tacle et
diffuser un certain nombre
d'informations classées secrètes pour
rétablir le déséquilibre entre eux les
puissants aux gouvernements les
entreprises et les simples citoyens
on a un vrai problème si ces pratiques
journalistiques là commence à être
poursuivi et effet et qui commence à
faire l'objet de l'acharnement
judiciaire comme c'est le cas pour
didier assange actuellement
alors on sait aussi que les etats-unis
reprochent à julian assange d'avoir tout
simplement mis en danger un des
personnes en divulguant certaines
informations comme enjeu une assange et
ses avocats peuvent qu'il se se
défendent de cela à ce que selon vous
les etats-unis sont de bonne foi dans
cette accusation
alors c'est effectivement le point
central que vous avez raison de
souligner c'est à dire que très vite
après la diffusion va pas rentrer dans
les détails des différentes fuites mais
très vite après la diffusion des fuites
concernant les exactions de l'armée
américaine en afghanistan en irak
l'administration américaine s'est mise à
dire que tous les ans en avait et geeks
avait du sang sur les mains et qui
mettaient en danger un certain nombre de
gens sur le terrain effectivement
l'armée américaine faisait appel à des
aléas des fixeurs locaux à d et à des
agents sur le terrain pour pour les
aider dans leurs dents dans leurs
actions sur le terrain il se trouve que
aucune preuve n'a été publié et nous n'a
été retrouvée par aucun ni médias ni
enquête notamment menée par le pentagone
pentagone au lendemain du procès manning
aucune preuve n'a été apportée du fait
potentiellement que les fuites de
wikileaks ait pu mener à mettre en
danger la vie d'un certain nombre de
gens sur le terrain reste à prouver
pour l'administration américaine le fait
que la fuite qui date de fin 2010 les
câbles diplomatiques de deux qui
concernent donc toute la diplomatie
américaine est mis en danger aussi des
agents sur le terrain on n'a toujours
pas de preuves de cette de cette
situation là merci beaucoup guillaume
ledit d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france merci à vous et toujours
au royaume uni si le break site est lui
bien acté c'est loin d'être le cas des
accords post break cite notamment sur la
question des eaux territoriales
britanniques
ce point semble ralentir voire bloquer
les discussions entre l'union européenne
et le royaume uni et pays sans vous
souhaitez bénéficier des eaux
territoriales abritent à michael
s'agirait là d'une question de survie
pour survie pour leurs pêcheurs
aujourd'hui les membres du conseil
européen notamment les négociations sur
un futur accord de partenariat
nous sommes prêts nous sommes prêts à
commencer cette nouvelle étape de la
négociation après le président
sur le fond nous maintenons notre niveau
d'ambition pour la future relation est
notre niveau d'exigence
bien entendu nous ne conclurons pas cet
accord à n'importe quel prix cette
négociation complexe exigeante dans un
temps
cours avant la sortie du royaume-uni du
marché unique de l'union douanière le 31
décembre prochain
si cette position britannique ne change
pas un temps très court qui est choisie
par le gouvernement britannique pas par
nous et chacun de ce point de vue là
devra assumer ses responsabilités et
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous reviendrons sur le port en navires
us deux nouveaux cas confirmés en france
ce soir et puis nous parlerons du
compteur linky dont les opposants sont
loin de baisser les bras et dépose une
action collective
[Musique]
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons
personne n'est content c'est à dire que
la désindustrialisation de la france
très très fort depuis 20 ans s'est
traduite par des fermeture de milliers
d'usinés
peu de gens osent le dire mais je le dis
il ya un retour en allemagne depuis une
dizaine d'années d'un mépris pour la
france parce que les allemands n'ont pas
compris qu'un pays adultes se laissent
des industrialisés comme nous l'avons
fait et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
devant encore vous dire que vous vous
comparer à l'allemagne je ne rentre pas
dans cette approche des gens qui
sous-estiment l'allemagne et l'allemagne
est en fait dans son insertion dans
l'économie mondiale dans la même
position que le japon donc l'allemagne a
n'est pas foutu est donc la clé serbe
pourrait être l'entente entre la france
et dalmat la question reste sur la table
dans la mesure où ça fait dix ans que
les allemands bloc toutes les salles
historiques
du matin 1 est pourquoi tu m'as tu là
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu vas te qu'es-tu mac os
alors à un vase il vient pas peur
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
ces [ __ ] de bassorah qu'est-ce qui
coule des tuyaux arty page amat m
voyez vous même ces lots de bassora il
avait été empoisonné par quoi barlow
vous jure cette eau est en train de nous
tuer à saurat était autrefois considérée
comme la venise du moyen-orient
aujourd'hui la ville fait face à la pire
crise de l'eau de l'histoire irakienne
d'espèces cet endroit était entouré de
forêt de palmiers à mon retour en 2003
j'étais vraiment sous le choc c'est de
l'eau du robinet de bassorah elle a
prétendument étaient nettoyés nous ne
voulons qu'à verre d'eau pour nos
enfants et nous mêmes
si nous n'avons pas d'eau nous n'avons
rien l'ofrou même le pétrole n'auront
plus aucun sens l'eau et tout ce qui
importe
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il lui arrive quelque chose tout
s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir si vous nous rejoignez pour
cette deuxième heures d'émission en
direct sur rt france voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi est deux
nouveaux cas de coronavirus en france
selon le ministère de la santé et qui
dès mi s'étend en europe où plus d'une
trentaine de pays sont désormais
concernés par des patients infectés pour
l' oms le monde n'est simplement pas
prêt face à l'épidémie
la menace du 49 3 se rapproche edouard
philippe laisse la porte ouverte à cette
possibilité afin de faire adopter son
vote le projet de réforme des retraites
alors que le débat parlementaire se
poursuit tant bien que mal au rythme des
invectives et des suspensions en séance
le 49 3 et qu il vraiment la seule issue
n'est ce pas une arme législative à
double tranchant ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face ce soit la france
pourront tout à ton désormais
ce n'était donc qu'un quittera la france
qui compte désormais 2 cas confirmés 2
coronavirus l'épidémie qui se propage en
europe des cas confirmés qui ont été
recensés en suisse en espagne en croatie
en autriche l'épidémie a fait 11 morts
dans le nord de l'italie et 322
personnes sont contaminées dans le pays
y compris en toscane en ligue oui et en
sicile malgré tout le ministre français
de la santé olivier verront réaffirme sa
volonté de ne pas fermer les frontières
et coûté à l'heure actuelle nous
souhaitons être extrêmement clair sur le
fait qu'il n'y a pas lieu de fermer les
frontières entre nos pays ce serait
disproportionné et efi et inefficace à
ce stade nous souhaitons également dire
qu'il n'ya pas lieu d'annuler a priori
les grands événements publics qu'ils
soient nature sportive ou culturelle
mais nous nous accordons la possibilité
au cas par cas de regarder chaque
situation en fonction de l'évaluation
que nous aurons de la part des autorités
scientifiques et sanitaires notamment
celles ci la fermeture des frontières
n'est pas d'actualité paris invite les
français à reporter leur voyage vers les
zones contaminées d'italie lors d'un
point presse le directeur général de la
santé au sein du ministère a exclu toute
restriction de circulation dans l'union
européenne
on a un besoin de solidarité au sein de
l'union européenne on voit bien
aujourd'hui que l'italie tire est
touchée que d'autres régions peuvent
être touchées on n'imagine pas en france
dire que les gens qui viennent
d'occitanie ou qui viennent de bretagne
ne doivent pas circuler ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens compte tenu de de
l'intensité des liens qui a entre
l'italie la france mais même entre
l'italie et l'autriche sont l'italie la
suisse en fait on pour l on pourrait
décliner avec tous les voisins
la circulation est permanente le virus
circule et ne évidemment ne s'arrête pas
aux frontières donc je pense qu'on est
plus sur une logique de renforcement de
l'information de l'ensemble des citoyens
concernés de réduction de la vie sociale
des personnes qui ont été vraiment dans
les zones les plus concernées ça c'est
important
si effectivement on était dans la zone
au circuit de virus il faut qu'on ait
une surveillance au personnel de son de
sa température et des signes cliniques
et de est d'être capable de mettre en
place des mesures barrières comme le
port du masque est extrêmement efficace
parce que le masque anti-projections est
justement fait pour éviter de projeter
des particules infectieuses et donc
c'est dans ce sens là que le plus le
masque est beaucoup plus utile comme
pour éviter de contaminer son entourage
et ses proches
l oms appelle le monde à se préparer à
une éventuelle pandémie du coronavirus
alors même que l'épidémie est en plein
déclin en chine foyer du virus
l'europe elle est donc aux prémices
d'une contamination en général le point
en images
[Musique]
veillez à ce que le dispositif français
soit prêt ça passe par la mise en en
vigilance d'un certain nombre de centres
hospitaliers
d'abord les chu puis 70 centres
supplémentaires ce qui veut dire que
partout en france où il ya un service de
sa bulle nous sommes prêts à accueillir
d'éventuels malades nous constatons
qu'il n'y a aucun malade hospitalisé en
france aujourd'hui atteints par ce virus
aucun aucun aucun à ce stade mais bien
évidemment nous sommes vigilants et nous
ferons toujours la transparence complète
c'est un cetain c'est une condition
indispensable de la confiance de nos
concitoyens et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis et ses terres au
royaume uni avec bharat ocaña expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir bar à tapas cagna merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors nous avons appris ce soir une deux
contaminations en france c'est officiel
est-ce que la situation en europe vous
inquiètent-elles c'est le cours naturel
des événements dans de tels cas
d'infection il y aura des infections
dans les pays d'origine comme la chine
puis et des cas dans d'autres régions du
monde
ce que nous devons faire c'est essayer
de limiter autant que possible le nombre
de cas c'est ce qu'on appelle le
confinement et c'est ce que nous faisons
en ce moment ça veut dire vraiment selon
vous le spécialiste médical que
clairement les autorités les pouvoirs
publics à les décisionnaires politiques
finalement aujourd'hui on la situation
grandement entre leurs mains c'était à
eux de jouer de prendre les bonnes
décisions dans chaque pays
je le pense et juin ce sont des
problèmes compliqués et n'est jamais une
réponse unique mais ce qui est important
c'est que nos actions soient en mesure
et non des actions de santé publique
afin de protéger les populations
mais il ne faut pas adopter des mesures
qui pourraient également leur nuire
quelles que soient les actions que nous
choisissons il faut réfléchir aux
avantages et aux inconvénients pour la
population il faut que l'action soit
scientifique bien informés et ensuite
que nous décidions et non pas dans
l'autre sens vous justement en tant que
responsable médical que médecin
qu'est-ce que vous attendriez
des pouvoirs publics on a vu que
certains et à fermer leurs frontières en
europe il ya eu cette discussion mais ce
n'est pas le cas évidemment par
définition c'est compliqué de fermer une
frontière en europe mais vous iriez vers
ce genre de mesures éviter finalement
tant que faire se peut les les
déplacements entre les états touchés
non je pense que la décision de manière
à l'ouverture des frontières et la bonne
car fermer les frontières ne sert à rien
cela on voit au contraire à un message
mauvais et le bon message c'est que nous
devons coopérer faut que nous fassions
preuve de responsabilité sociale afin de
réduire le nombre des cas il s'agit de
ne pas se rendre dans un foyer
d'infection et ne veut pas non plus
sortir de ce foyer
si on aurait pu être infecté ainsi en
travaillant de concert peut bien mieux
s'en tirer et c'est bien supérieur à
l'idée de fermer les frontières car cela
ne permet pas d'atteindre le résultat
escompté alors outre-manche ans chez
vous dès le 19 février il était dit que
le coronavirus arrêté je cite une menace
grave et imminente
est ce que on doit vraiment s'inquiéter
pourquoi cette maladie finalement fait
elle aussi peur c'est une très bonne
occasion de rassurer votre public
c'est la situation est préoccupante
parce que c'est un nouveau virus et que
certaines personnes tombent malades
mais mon message principal c'est que la
plupart des personnes sont infectées et
se remettront sans quelques personnes
auront besoin de consulter un médecin
et parmi ces quelques personnes qui
consultent un médecin
seules quelques-unes
nombreux traits limiteur ont besoin
d'une hospitalisation et certaines
personnes seulement auront besoin de
soins intensifs
il faut remettre la situation dans son
contexte
la plupart des personnes même si elles
sont infectées guérir et c'était un
message très important pour le public
nous ne voulons pas les inquiéter
inutilement car cela serait mal est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une étude sur le
profil des victimes
il ya eu évidemment plusieurs plus de
2000 morts en chine 1 je crois d'autres
morts ailleurs dans le monde est ce qu'à
un recul suffisant pour savoir pour qui
c'est dangereux et pour qui ça l'est
moins comme vous nous l'avez expliqué en
somme c'est tout et toute cette épidémie
depuis enrayer l'apparition de la
maladie à la mi décembre en chine
donc nous en apprenons ce que nous
savons et calmement c'est que selon ce
sont surtout les personnes âgées qui
sont touchés et les personnes qui ont
des commodités comme des maladies
cardiaques du foie ou des reins nous
devons rester conscient du fait que
puisqu'il s'agit d'un homme virus alors
effectivement il peut attaquer n'importe
qui mais les personnes qui en souffrent
le plus sont les personnes âgées qui ont
déjà d'autres maladies concomitante
donc je souhaite une fois de plus
rassurer vos auditeurs des personnes
peuvent être infectés mais en règle
générale un pourcentage très petit de la
population sont plus touchés que
d'autres aussi beaucoup d'inquiétudes
évidemment pour les parents pour leurs
enfants notamment des parents d'enfants
asthmatiques y en a beaucoup dans les
grandes villes est ce qu'on a là aussi
du recul pour ces types de profils
est-ce que c'est plus dangereux vont pas
tout à fait cette information nous ne
savons pas ce qu'ils arrivent
spécifiquement aux enfants qui souffrent
d'une condition particulière notamment
de l'asthme
mais la précaution et générales le
conseil général c'est qu'il faut
maintenir des conditions d'hygiène bonne
éviter les endroits où il ya beaucoup de
monde et cela ne nous affectera pas si
vous êtes loin de quelqu'un car cela se
propage à proximité avec les
gouttelettes de salive
il faut donc se lavent éléments se laver
les mains avec de l'eau chaude et du
savon et il faut surtout se sécher les
mains des mains propres et sèches sont
très importantes pour éviter le
coronavirus de plus il faut se laver les
mains avant de manger et c'est un
message de santé publique très important
merci beaucoup en tout cas baratte
pagani un expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter de
nous avoir un petit peu rassuré nos
téléspectateurs en tout cas en direct
sur rt france ce soir merci à vous et
cette question les agriculteurs sont ils
réellement gagnant dans la réforme des
retraites le projet de loi du
gouvernement français prévoit qu'une
pension minimum de 1000 euros une
requête au dessus de la moyenne actuelle
mais pour en bénéficier le texte pose
des conditions qu'une grande partie des
agriculteurs ne peuvent remplir les
explications de solenn gaudin 1000 euros
nets de retraite par mois pour les
agriculteurs à partir de 2022
sur le papier la réforme devrait réjouir
le monde agricole
en moyenne les retraites s'élève à 760
euros par mois pour les hommes et 580
pour les femmes selon un rapport de
l'insee de 2016
des pensions en dessous de la moyenne
française 1390 euros en 2017 selon
l'insee et du seuil de pauvreté 2010
9041 euros problème cette réforme est
loin de concerner tous les agriculteurs
seuls les chefs d'exploitation ayant
fait une carrière complète de 43 ans et
ont cotisé à hauteur du smic pourront en
bénéficier sont exclues notamment les
conjoints des agriculteurs qui
travaillent dans l'exploitation ou
encore les agriculteurs qui ont connu
des interruptions dans leurs activités
pour diverses raisons
40% des paysans ne serait donc pas
éligibles à cette retraite plancher
selon le rapport de le voir une
désillusion donc pour les agriculteurs
bah oui mille euros ça peut être correct
parce que dans les conditions de vie
qu'on peut avoir ou les trains de vie
qu'on peut avoir
voilà ça peut être quelque chose de bien
après les conditions si elles sont trop
compliqués très longue peut-être qu'on
aura de toute façon jamais non plus 7 7
semble aujourd'hui la retraite des
paysans jouer comme mes parents c'est
ses 700 ou 800 euros maximum
donc on entend dire un mille euros on
sait déjà un premier pas mais c'est un
millime en cage faudrait même un peu
plus parce que c'est vrai que vis-à-vis
des autres corporations on est on risque
d'être encore à la traîne quand même
autre revendication
l'application de ce plafond de 1000
euros aux agriculteurs déjà à la
retraite
ça fait plus de deux ans qu'on réclame
cette revalorisation des retraites
agricoles qui est très très basse et qui
est même la plus basse aujourd'hui
en france qu' on nous a mis en avant
justement le remaniement de 7
de l'ensemble des retraites pour
l'ensemble des corporations et que
aujourd'hui on est en stand by on attend
toujours une revalorisation aujourd'hui
sur le terrain on voit des gens qui
veulent plus prendre la retraite parce
qu'ils ont intérêt à continuer à faire
leur métier alors qu'ils ont dépassé
l'âge espoirs balayé par emmanuel macron
samedi dernier au salon de l'agriculture
tous ceux qui rentreront dans le nouveau
système contrairement à l'ancien ils
auront une garantie de retraite minimum
est ce que je peux vous dire tous les
agriculteurs retraités d'aujourd'hui
peuvent rentrer c'est impossible c'est
impossible parce que c'est un coude 1,1
milliard et incompréhension des
syndicats qui réclament une
revalorisation des pensions des 1,3
million d'agriculteurs déjà à la
retraite
aujourd'hui on a eu and yet samedi du
président de la république sur ce public
là nous on demande à ce qu'ils aient une
reprise de ces retraités actuels
aujourd'hui si c'est pas dans la loi et
on le savait très bien que ce serait pas
dans la loi que ce soit traitée en
parallèle on avait légué quand même des
engagements de la ministre de la santé
qui est plus là aujourd'hui agnès buzyn
comme quoi ça serait traitée en
parallèle la loi aujourd'hui le
président de la république
notez que ça sera traité dans la
prochaine loi de finances on a besoin de
certitudes et de faire application
cette revalorisation pourrait donc voir
le jour dans la prochaine loi de
finances mais à condition que des
propositions de financement soit fait
selon le ministère de l'agriculture
malgré la réforme qu'ils soient déjà
retraités ou non
nombreux sont les agriculteurs qui
devront donc compter sur le minimum
vieillesse
rt france sous le coup d'une procédure
lancée par le csa en cause un sujet
diffusé en avril 2019 une audience aura
lieu demain avant que le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel ne rende sa
décision sur une éventuelle sanction
les détails avec thomas bonnet cette
procédure de sanction ouverte contre
verte et france l'a été suite à la
diffusion d'un sujet en avril 2019
dans ce sujet il est fait état de
déclarations d'un général russe à propos
de la syrie pour en parler je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre de jérôme
bonnet rédacteur en chef de rtl france
la question est de savoir si les propos
polémiques d'un haut dignitaire
militaires russes représentent de
l'intérêt pour le public
pour moi la réponse est oui à condition
que des pays qu'il met en cause est
également voix au chapitre et puisse
répondre ce qui est le cas dans ce sujet
là on est vraiment dans la pratique la
plus élémentaires du journalisme
effectivement il ya une polémique donc
on explique d'où elle vient qu'elles
font les accusations portées et puis les
mises en cause peuvent répondre et après
notre audience de se faire son opinion
une audience publique va donc avoir lieu
ce mercredi 26 février pour audience au
cours de laquelle rt france va être
entendues par le csa et on verra si le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel suit
l'avis du rapporteur indépendant qui a
préconisé de ne pas sanctionner notre
média réponse dans les toutes prochaines
heures en france et n'existe contre
attaque la société estime que le
déploiement du compteur linky se déroule
dans de bonnes conditions et que 90% des
clients en sont satisfaits alors que des
avocats appellent à une action
collective en justice contre elle et 10
en cause ce fameux petit boîtier verts
on vous a peut-être poser chez vous
après le lancement d'une pétition signée
par douze mille personnes deux avocats
entendent faire respecter les droits des
consommateurs ils veulent obliger les 10
à ne plus installer
de linky dans les foyers qui n'en
veulent pas et à retirer au besoin ses
boîtiers existants ils refusent tiges la
pression qu'exerce kennedy sur ses
clients quand vous êtes consommateur
vous recevez des appels téléphoniques
des textos des mails
oui vous avez des sous traitants d'année
10 qui passe chez vous qui vous disent
que c'est obligatoire que c'est gratuit
ce qui étonne double mensonge et pour
les personnes qui sont pas informés ou
qui font confiance est née disent ils
acceptent d'ouvrir la porte de laisser
des installateurs modifier l'équipe en
tenant son jeu très simple puisqu'on
vous dit en permanence c'est obligatoire
et c'est gratuit
or pour c'est gratuit on a un texte de
loi qui le contraire donc cette
problématique
et pour cette obligatoire en revanche
n'a pas de textes de doigts on ne sait
pas sur quel article s'appuie aînés 10
pour dire aux consommateurs
vous ne pouvez pas refuser si un
consommateur en faire demande et les 10
fera la sourde oreille dont il se
passera rien c'est pour ça que après une
mise en demeure que nous avons fait au
mois de janvier une réponse qui nous a
pas satisfaite que nous avons reçu
dernièrement nous sommes obligés de
passer par la voie judiciaire permettre
aux consommateurs qui veulent protéger
de voir l'intervention une rendement
d'un juge impartial qui veut dire année
10 arrêtez vous l'utilisent respecter à
la fois la vie privée et de domiciles
privés des consommateurs est retirée ou
n'installez pas les équipements le
compteur linky s'est passé un peu un
compteur qui va mesurer votre
consommation d'électricité ça c'est la
consommation globale elle va mesurer
aussi le comportement d'achat en quelque
sorte des consommateurs en identifiant
les appareils qui sont connectés la
durée d'utilisation et même avec la
signature qui est laissée par ces
appareils ne va pas elle va pouvoir
déterminer s'ils sont obsolètes ou neuf
et ça ça va permettre ensuite en
récupérant ces informations à une et dix
de les revendre pour justement permettre
à des sociétés commerciales vous
proposer de changer votre vie et
équipements par un nouveau la loi que
sur la loi informatique et liberté
boulevard j [ __ ] européens prévoient que
le consommateur doit donner un accord
particulier pour l'utilisation qui sera
faite des données et la haine et lisa
bus de sa position dominante
si vous voulez l'électricité ok cliquez
là et en même temps vous acceptez que
toutes les informations que je vais
récolter soit transféré à qui je veux en
droit français nous avons une action de
groupe qui était un piège procédural que
nous voulons éviter dont nous avons
inventé ou re découvert l'action
collective conjointe qui permet à tout
un tas de personnes qui ne se
connaissent pas de se réunir autour
d'une même procédure pour agir ensemble
et par cette réunion nous avons réussi
en quelque sorte à casser les prix
puisque une procédure normale ou teinte
de et 5000 euros
là nous arrivons à proposer les services
des avocats pour 200 euros et on va même
plus loin que je comprends que c'est 200
euros ça peut être une somme importante
pour des consommateurs on a réussi à
lisser cette somme sur 24 mois ce qui
fait que c'est un abonnement à un
service qui coûte 1 8 euros par mois la
démarche vise encore une fois à protéger
les consommateurs
c'est à dire qu'avec cette procédure
seuls ceux qui font la demande d'être
protégé par la justice seront justement
protéger
si vous n'êtes pas dans la procédure est
né dix pourra continuer à faire ce
qu'elle veut autrement dit on ne cherche
pas à interdire de linky on cherche
simplement à faire en sorte que ceux qui
n'en veulent pas soit entendu
la 43ème session du conseil des droits
de l'homme de l'onu se poursuit à genève
mon cette deuxième journée la question
du désarmement est au coeur des échanges
des 40 pays participants sergueï lavrov
a pointé du doigt la politique
américaine en la matière le retrait
unilatéral des états unis du traité sur
les forces nucléaires intermédiaire
suscite une grande inquiétude pour la
communauté internationale c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le chef de la diplomatie russe
le point avec notre reporter à genève
cathy appétit et notamment le ministre
des affaires étrangères russe sergueï
lavrov a prononcé deux discours l'un à
la conférence de désarmement et le
second au conseil des droits de l'homme
alors concernant la conférence de
désarmement il a précisé deux objectifs
l'un c'est la limitation de la course
aux armements spatiaux sur la base d'un
projet de traité élaboré avec la chine
est le second c'est l'élaboration d'une
convention internationale pour lutter
contre les actes de terrorisme
biologique et chimique
mais surtout il a mené une lourde charge
contre washington
il accuse les etats-unis de se détourner
des efforts communs de tous les états
pour enrayer la course aux armements
pour preuve il a rappelé que les états
unis s'étaient retirés de nombreux
traités ou alors ne souhaitait pas les
renouveler et ce malgré les propositions
de la russie
donc il ya évidemment le traité start ou
encore le traité effet ni je vous
propose de l'écouter à ce sujet nous
voyons aujourd'hui de manifestations
d'agression et d'égocentrisme de la part
d'un pays et le retrait de washington en
2002 de traité abm qui était très
important a été un coup porté à tous là
l'ensemble de la construction dans le
domaine de la maîtrise des armements et
ces derniers temps la politique des
américains se manifeste dans une volonté
d'ingérence partout et d'imposer selon
son intérêt à l'ensemble de
la communauté internationale en une
infraction au droit international le
retrait unilatéral des états unis de
l'accord est finie suscite une grande
inquiétude pour l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale n'est dont la
russie en déclarant qu'elle sera obligé
de répondre par la réciproque à au
déploiement d'armes américaine prend
l'engagement de ne pas développer ces
armements basés au sol tant qu il n'y
aura pas de d'équivalent américains sur
place
nous proposons aux américains et leurs
alliés un moratoire analogues et j'en
profite pour rappeler que il faut
dissiper les soupçons qui répondent
actuellement nous sommes pour un régime
de vérification mutuelle
sayah lavrov s'est ensuite exprimé au
pupitre du conseil des droits de l'homme
devant lequel je me trouve
il a tout d'abord dénoncé ce qu'il
estime être un double standard des
démocraties occidentales en matière de
droits de l'homme et la citant en
exemple l'ukraine selon lui à des
minorités ils seraient bafoués mais
également les pays baltes ou des
groupuscules néo nazi et xénophobe
resurgirait et cela dans l'indifférence
des nations occidentales
mais il faut aussi noter que diverses
personnalités ici ont dénoncé la
situation en syrie à idleb et à cela
sert il abreuve a répliqué qu'il fallait
combattre le terrorisme et ne pas
capituler
d'ailleurs en parlant de terrorisme
sergueï lavrov a estimé que son
expansion était due à une crise
migratoire sans précédent une crise que
les états devraient s'engager à résoudre
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir des discours
aujourd'hui de sergueï lavrov à genève
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
notre débat sur le 49-3 une arme
législative parfois décrié qui
permettrait de faire adopter son vote le
projet de réforme des retraites
est ce la seule issue pour sortir d'un
débat parlementaire sans fin nous en
débattrons avec nos impôts
t
[Musique]
le numérique ça et mais aujourd'hui 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
tous les citoyens qui utilisent par
exemple des ordinateurs polluent la
planète
à chaque fois qu'on a une requête
internet qu'on envoie un email
qu'on l'ait qu'une photo sur instagram
ça en impact carbone un email envoyé
avec une pièce jointe
c'est l'équivalent d'une ampoule allumée
pendant une heure comme ceci
peu de gens ont conscience que le
numérique pollue pire encore ils pensent
que le numérique est un outil qui
permettrait de réduire la consommation
d'énergie le numérique est en quelque
sorte un pharmaco en pharma concept un
mot grec ancien qui veut dire à la être
à la fois remède est poison c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il faut
utiliser avec
avec sagesse avec mesure ce qui fera le
plus de bien à la planète foot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fort potentiel qui gagnent moins et
je ferai que ce que tu veux toi tu es un
gros bout on est des êtres humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents donc
les deux parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmet ce qu'ils
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui soit
exposé apporte ses gants ses vêtements
on leur met leur masque avec la visière
qui leur permet de regarder à
l'extérieur
une fois qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux
pas qu'elle ait une vie où il reste tout
le temps à la maison c'est pas une vie
tu auras la vie comme tout le monde et
ça je le ferai tout pour que ça soit le
cas
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six interdit d'interdire
21h30 heure française bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez en direct sur rt france
edouard philippe demande aux députés de
la majorité de tenir encore face à
l'obstruction de l'opposition sur la
réforme des retraites
le premier ministre l'a sûr si besoin il
prendra ses responsabilités en recourant
au fameux 49,3 écouté lorsqu'il faut
prendre ses responsabilités je le fais
sans hésiter et j'utilise tout la
constitution rien que la constitution
mais bien toute la constitution il
appartient monsieur le président à
l'assemblée nationale elle-même de faire
vivre ce débat
si ce débat vie et qu'il permet
d'avancer dans de bonnes conditions tant
mieux c'est ce que je souhaite mais à
partir d'un certain moment il faut être
clair nous nous sommes engagés sur ce
système universel de retraite par
répartition et par point et l'engagement
du gouvernement le fait majoritaire
ça existe en attendant les débats se
poursuivent à l'assemblée pour protester
contre ces réformes une autre forme que
les débats à l'assemblée une marque de 8
jours a été organisée elle est arrivée
aujourd'hui à paris des membres de la
société civile des syndicats des élus
notamment de la france insoumise ont
quitté laval en mayenne lundi dernier et
protestataires qui dénoncent que
possible le recours aux 49 3 on écoute
les leaders de la france assume
clairement il vaut mieux qu'ils
réfléchissent à ce qu'ils font parce que
moi je reçois beaucoup de messages
je ne l'imaginé pas
un impact pareil sur la sensibilité du
public beaucoup de gens sont ont compris
qu'ils avaient le risque du 49-3 il ya
déjà des consignes de rassemblement
autour de l'assemblée si le 49 3 et
décidez donc je pense qu'il ya où il ya
de l'émotion dans le pays et qu'ils
doivent le savoir auprès de maquereaux
et d'edouard philippe ils doivent se
demander alors ce matin nous a fait un
petit numéro à la conférence des
présidents le président de l'assemblée
nous a dit à ben attash et de prévoir
votre procuration pour les deux tours
des élections municipales parce que vous
serez dans l'hémicycle ça sent la ruse
alors en quoi consiste concrètement le
49-3 la réponse en images
[Musique]
oh
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le quart entre une 49,3 est il
vraiment la seule issue n'est ce pas une
arme législative à double tranchant
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir pour en débattre nous sommes avec
frédéric à la tour président d'honneur
du club vaugirard bonsoir frédéric
latour merci d'être avec nous à ses
côtés david guiraud porte-parole bonsoir
jeunesse la france
insoumise merci à tous les deux d'être
là alors on a entendu edouard philippe
en dire que la france insoumise en gros
puisque c'est le parti qui est
responsable de la majorité des
amendements faisait obstruction
obstruction le mot vous êtes d'accord
avec avec sa david biraud ben écoutez le
gouvernement il est parti avec une
stratégie est claire il le dit depuis le
début c'est qu'ils veulent éviter que la
loi dépasse les municipales pourquoi
parce qu'aux municipales et n'ose
prendre une raclée
donc ils veulent pas s'encombrer d'une
loi qui après les municipales
après le suffrage c'est à dire un vote
des français apparaissent comme un comme
une vote sanction et que derrière ils
doivent assumer une loi qui est encore
plus compliquée à assumer c'est ça la
stratégie nous on a dit qu'on avait
besoin juste de débats vous avez une
conférence de financement aujourd'hui
des députés de la france un sony ils ont
dit repoussons le vote de la loi après
la conférence de financement mais pas
pour des raisons absurdes
parce qu'aujourd'hui des députés ce qui
sont les gens qui sont censés faire la
loi qui sont censés être les
représentants de la nation
edouard philippe a tendance à l'oublier
il se prend pour le législateur n'en
sait les députés les législateurs ne
savent pas les conséquences de ce qu'ils
vont voter gars 29 ordonnance et une
conférence de financement il ya des
indicateurs
par exemple on nous dit on nous l'a dit
pendant la séance et heureusement
qu'elle de l'obstruction comme ils
appellent ça mais pendant la séance on
apprend quelque chose c'est que le point
la valeur du point des futures retraites
il sera calculé à partir d'un indicateur
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
voilà donc vous de ces gens-là demanda
députés à des députés de voter sur des
indicateurs qui n'existe pas à partir
d'une conférence de financement cas pas
eu lieu
et avec énormément d'inconnu et de
trahison en plus parce que les
agriculteurs et les professeurs c'est
une des choses qu'on a appris en séance
des trahisons de certaines professions
va évidemment il faut du temps pour le
débat par exemple quand on avait
privatisé
pas que tf1 avait mis deux mois pourquoi
est-ce que sur une réforme qui va tuer
70 ans 70 ans parce que c'est depuis 45
le système de retraite pour ce presque
une réforme qui va tuer 70 ans de notre
histoire sociale doit être fait en deux
semaines
c'est incompréhensible donc c'est pas de
l'obstruction c'est au delà de ça c'est
juste du bon sens parlementaire le fait
de que les députés examinent sereinement
sérieusement la loi et ce à tous les
députés de tous les bords le demande on
va aller plus loin justement ces essais
on comprend aussi la stratégie parce
qu'elle est aussi critique et vous savez
par par des gens qui sont évidemment
contre ce projet de loi vous frédéric
latour vous trouvé la méthode de la
france en soumises et des communistes
constructive plus de 40 mille
amendements des débats bloqués et
peut-être 1 49 3 qui avance tout cas la
menace de 49,3 qui avance méchamment non
mais c'est vrai que c'est énorme 40000
un moment je reprenais certains
amendements qui sur des amendements
purement fantaisistes vous savez il ya
toujours eu je pense notamment aux lois
bioéthiques qui a toujours eu énormément
d'un moment sur des textes comme ça mais
le gouvernement par sa méthode
le gouvernement a voulu passer en force
et faire voter ce texte au moment des
municipales et je crois que les députés
en marche qui sont pour la plupart des
députés qui n'ont jamais fait de
politique de leur vie vont découvrir que
il faudra pas passer le week-end avec
ses enfants dit sa femme il va falloir
aller aux à l'assemblée nationale
travaille et les amendements il ya des
amendements qui sont assez étonnants
avec des virgules près sur des mots et
ça c'est tout à fait regrettable
par contre il ya ce débat parlementaire
l'agitation du 49-3 est purement
scandaleux parce qu'en réalité il ya eu
trois débats sur les retraites en 93 en
2003 et en 2010
la droite n'a jamais utilisé le 49 3 et
là sous prétexte que le gouvernement
souhaite impérativement faire voter ce
texte avant les municipales
il peut de toute façon leur porte et je
vous rappelle que senna après va
s'emparer va s'emparer de ce tacle donc
je trouve que la méthode du gouvernement
est assez étonnante j'entendais tout à
l'heure le premier ministre qui a l'air
de faire un pas sur le 49-3 on est dans
la même situation qui à l'époque sur la
loi une connerie
sauf que faire ce 49 3 alors que la
majorité des députés en marche et 304
des pleurs 577
c'est ça qui est très étonnant le
gouvernement veut passer en force
parce qu'il sait très bien qui sera
sanctionnée dans les urnes au moment des
élections d'ici populaire surtout cessé
il ya une aberration quelque chose qui
est quasiment jamais vu c'est que c'est
une majorité parlementaire qui sut
publié un gouvernement d'utiliser une
arme anti parlementaire c'est quand même
du jamais vu c'est à dire que ses
députés la delà de la république en mars
font tellement lobotomisés qu'ils en
viennent à demander à eux mêmes se faire
piétiner sur les amendements will 40000
c'est beaucoup et enfin edf en 2006
étaient 130 milles 1 donc on a été
gentil je préfère le dire et quand même
et surtout il ya des amendements vous
savez il y en a 17 par députés ont
l'utilisent pour que juste chaque député
puisse parler au moment de l'amendement
mais parlante dimanche dernier et vous
allez un bar à oui mais mais tous les
amendements sont pas défendus 17 fois
mais par exemple dimanche dernier la
france insoumise a défendu 30 ou 40
amendements et ce qu'ils font c'est
drôle parce que son qui nous accusent d'
obstruction mais est souvent c'est les
députés en marche alors vous avez un
membre de la france est soumise aux
communistes qui fait une intervention
et si vous en avez un ou deux dans
marche derrière qui fait une
intervention qu'on a appelé les
interventions - c'est-à-dire une
intervention où les gens se plaignent
qu'il ya des amendements quand vous
faites deux interventions vous
pleurnichez ont une autre intervention
vous doublez déjà le temps de parole
voyez 30 à 40 à mon nom en effet desoler
une journée s'est pas non plus
insurmontable
et je dis ça parce que la france a
soumises notamment dimanche avait
proposé et les autres groupes politiques
autres que la république en acheter
d'accord on avait proposé de passer à un
autre article
on avait passé aurait proposé 2
justement de finir avec l'article 1 et
passer à d'autres articles de fond mais
qui c'est qu'a refusé ça c'est la
république en large parce qu'ils sont en
train de jouer à un jeu de rôle
extrêmement pernicieux ou en gros soit
disant il ya des il ya de l'obstruction
parlementaire maui il ya une opposition
parlementaire désolé de vous dire
qu'elle existe et que l'on fait notre
travail c'est sa députée fin mais vous
savez d'ailleurs bonvaux vos dirigeants
ne s'en sont pas cachés qu'il ya
peut-être un tout petit peu de mauvaise
foi dans la nature même des amendements
est ce qu'on se trompe pas de débat on
discute effectivement de la virgule du
point et pas du fond du problème
non mais j'entends mais à quel moment
est ce que vous avez entendu moi
j'aimerais qu'on me dise à quel moment
est ce que quelqu'un a entendu un député
de la france insoumise dire faire une
intervention de deux minutes c'est ça le
temps de l'intervention sur amendement
sur la virgule sait jamais ça nous on
fait des interventions de fond c'est un
prétexte pour parler du fond et pourquoi
on fait ça parce que depuis le début on
peut pas en parler du fond depuis le
début on a des on a on à la république
en marche qui nous a multiplié un nombre
de facs news multiplier un nombre
d'inconnues qui fait qu'on est obligé de
se rajouter du temps d'intervention pour
parler de choses qu'on n'aurait jamais
parlé avant je vous ai parlé de
l'indicateur inconnu ça a été discuté
parce que justement il ya eu des
amendements par pour en parler sur les
professeurs le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité il a été soulevée
pendant la séance en hémicycle et en
commission vous voyez à chaque fois
qu'il ya des arguments des amendements
c'est pas pour dire bon alors pendant
deux minutes je vais parler de la
virgule elle veut faire semblant
d'intervenir c'est toujours des
positions de fond qui sont apportées et
des positions qui je pense intéresse les
français
moi j'ai rarement eu tellement lancé sur
les réseaux s'il en est résulté une de
mes prochaines questions est ce que
quand on est français tout simplement
devant voilà sans téléviseur devant la
presse est ce qu'on n'est pas privé de
ce débat là est ce que en français qui a
envie de savoir à quelle sauce il va
être mangé par ce projet de retraite il
se retrouve pas un peu spoliés de ce
débat qu'il a peut-être lui permettre de
le savoir
justement je pense pas parce que quand
vous regardez les débats ces débats de
fond c'est à dire que la france entend
disposer des poses des questions de fond
les républicains pose des questions de
fond les communistes pose des questions
de fond les seuls qui sont en train de
se noyer dans le débat c'est les députés
de la majorité qui découvrent leurs
propres textes de loi ils savent pas qui
va calculer tel indicateur est ce que
céline c'est le conseil d'état bon bah
au moins les français se rendent compte
de ça et moi je vous le dis très
honnêtement de ce que je vois comme
retour de la part des citoyens que ce
soit sur les réseaux sociaux etc
le fait qu'il y ait un débat
parlementaire ça les intéresse à la
question et c'est pas que pour les
moments un peu pimenté où ça chauffe en
hémicycle etc
c'est parce que à chaque fois que vous
que vous allumez aujourd'hui le direct
de l'assemblée nationale vous voyez des
choses intéressantes vous
rené des chaussures la loi et de tous
bords politiques confondus donc moi je
je sais pas ce qu'il faut de plus moi
pour moi c'est de l'animation de la vie
démocratique c'est ça la démocratie
parlementaire c'est des gens en
discutent ils sont pas d'accord parfois
ils s'engueulent mais au moins ça permet
d'avoir une meilleure compréhension de
ce qui se passe et les français sont
longtemps aujourd'hui de comprendre
exactement ça ils sont en train de
comprendre que les agriculteurs la
retraite à 1000 euros elle sera pas
possible que les professeurs le
soi-disant la revalorisation ça serait
anticonstitutionnel que les avocats pour
l'instant n'y a toujours pas de réponse
que les égoutiers qui meurent à centre à
62 ans en moyenne vont partir en
retraite à 62 ans c'est à dire l'âge
auquel humeur parce qu'on a supprimé le
labour va essayer de répondre avant
qu'on écoute aussi le l'opinion d'autres
politiques mais voilà vous avez le même
temps de réponse et mercier le principal
problème c'est qu'il faudrait pas tomber
dans une opposition de façade et de
principe la france insoumise qui était
un groupe parlementaire de 17 députés
elle fait quelque part une petite partie
de l'obstruction je vous disais tout à
l'heure il ya des amendements en de là
au delà des virgules
et ça ça décrédibilise la vie politique
on a face à nous des députés en marche
qui ont pour certains un niveau délégués
de classe de 4e qui n'ont jamais compris
je ne savais même pas justifier leur
vote
salle des quatre colonnes c'est
incroyable je discutais avec des
collaborateurs parlementaires qui
apprennent le métier de député
vous rendez compte l'abaissement de la
vie politique avec les députés en mars
et face à ça il faut une opposition qui
soit une opposition responsable
une opposition qui fasse des
propositions moi je m'inscris quelque
part dans la lignée de ce qu'a pu dire
tout à l'heure damien abad une
opposition irresponsable de la part des
républicains
une partie propositions il faut pas
refaire le débat de la présidentielle
dans la rue et à l'assemblée et c'est
très bien que y est les groupes comme la
france a soumise comme le groupe
communiste comme le groupe socialiste
qui fasse des propositions de fond mais
la face à un abaissement de la vie
politique qu'on a effectivement jamais
connu avec les députés en marche c'est
d'ailleurs un des problème du cumul des
mandats parce qu'on se rencontre on a
éludé amateurs qui ne comprennent même
pas le propre texte rappelez vous la
vidéo
deux corps une bio qui arrivait même pas
justifiée le texte sur les retraites
donc il faut pas de 49 3 mais il faut en
même temps que les débats soient plus
compréhensif vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un français qui regardent les débats à
la télé sur les retraites
le français il va pas tout comprendre il
va pas tout comprendre david parlait d'
exemple qui sont plus concrets et il
faudrait que les députés facilite un
petit peu leur langage pour que ce débat
soit utile
encore une fois le gouvernement veut
passer en force avant le 15 mars il est
là le principal problème ça va forcer
les députés à revenir et revenir sauf
que je suis désolé vu la majorité
parlementaire des 304 députés en marche
elle n'a pas besoin de ce 49 3 et c'est
lui qui a calqué le vote avant le
premier tour du 15 mai on va
véritablement arrivé sans doute entre le
premier et le deuxième tour mais je
crois qu'il faut que les députés
certains soient plus dans le fond et pas
dans la forme
c'est important d'être dans le fond et
la forme quelque part elle est un petit
peu étonnante
on va écouter attendait avant de
poursuivre ce débat on va aller
justement écouter les différents
responsables politiques voient des
politiques en tout cas de tous bords sur
cette utilisation du 49-3 aujourd'hui
nous avons un texte constitutionnel qui
est bien pensée la constitution fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand on la respecte
on est dans la démocratie ce n'est pas
antidémocratique que de faire le 49-3 le
49 3 c'est de la démocratie
si 49 3 il doit y avoir
ça ne doit pas être un 49,3 couperet
bête et méchant prenant tels que le
texte initial
il doit tenir compte de toutes les
dynamiques politiques internes de ce que
le groupe porte comme amélioration
ce que nous voulons c'est que le texte
qui sortira
quelle que soit la procédure procédure
normale ou procédures 49,3 soit enrichie
de tout le travail énorme que nous avons
produit et les ruelles bloque tout pour
justifier le 49-3 à l'assemblée les
maquereaux nist refusent les
propositions de plusieurs groupes pour
faire avancer les débats
ils bloquent tout pour justifier le 49-3
et quand on leur dit il coupe le micro
le 49 3 fut créée pour contraint d'une
majorité pas pour faire taire
l'opposition pour limiter les débats le
gouvernement a le temps législatif
programmé
s'il ne l'a pas à utiliser c'est que son
texte n'était pas prêt les français
subissent l'amateurisme de la république
en marche un seul article adopté sur 65
en huit jours soit la france insoumise
le pcf arrêtent leur logique de blocage
soit l'option du 49-3 sera naturellement
ouverte
notre groupe il sera prêt car on croit
fondamentalement à cette réforme
david guiraud ans sans évidemment qu'un
enjeu politique majeur là en dessous
mais enfin tout de même vous n'avez pas
peur de porter la responsabilité je me
fais provoqué prises volontairement
d'avoir un texte finalement qui ont été
adoptées par le gouvernement c'est ce
qu'il voulait imposer à tous les
français mais qui n'aura pas été
effectivement débattu avec ces
amendements qui ont poussé le
gouvernement à faire ce 49 3 bat pour
moi les débats de forme de fonds des
amendements c'est du blabla il ya une
réalité c'est qu'ils veulent aller le
plus vite possible
ils veulent donner à l'assemblée
nationale deux semaines pour examiner un
texte qui chamboule 45 plus de 70 ans de
notre vie sociale
voilà c'est ça la vérité c'est pas le
reste le reste c'est du marketing
concentration m et d'entre elles
écartent ext oui mais ça ne sait rien
soyez sûr d'une chose c'est qu'il y ait
des que jelen les amendements de la
france insoumise ou pas même que y est
la france en soumises ou pas il aurait
voulu le faire mais qu'il attendait
certes elle que ça que j'essaye de vous
mais nous on alors je pense pas qu'on
leur rendre service parce qu'on leur a
mis quand même le nez dans la gadoue
plusieurs fois donc et ça c'est de la
responsable responsabilité on a bien
fait notre travail
maintenant si c'est trop dur pour les
gens d'entendre que un texte qui
chamboule tout là tout tout tout tout
notre vie sociale ne puisse pas être
examiné en six ou sept semaines ou huit
semaines c'est-à-dire d'attendre la
conférence de financement mais
normalement il n'y a pas besoin de se
presser qui ont la recette a lancé le
49-3 demi
soyez sûrs d'une chose ils n'ont dans
tous les cas soyez sûr d'une autre chose
c'est qu'ils vont faire tout ce qui est
possible et tout ce qui est en leur
pouvoir pour aller de manière la plus
anti démocratique possible parce que moi
entre 1 et 1 49 3 qui est fait en deux
semaines ou texte est examiné en deux
semaines parce qu'ils ont la majorité
absolue quel est le seul endroit du pays
où ils ont la majorité
ils l'ont pas au conseil d'état parce
que les textes les institutions
juridiques du pays les ont laminé ils
l'ont pas dans la rue ils n'ont pas de
bases sociales dont l'opinion il
n'existe pas le seul endroit où ils ont
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale donc
moi je veux bien avoir un débat sur le
49-3 mais la vérité c'est que de toute
façon dans deux semaines ils veulent ils
veulent que ça soit terminé et fini ont
rempli les valises on y va c'est ce
alors leur but politique donc nous on a
une opposition politique
on voit ça on dit non non attendez vous
n'allez pas vous en tirer comme ça
d'accord et les yeux aussi le fait
qu'ils soient obligés de recourir aux
cadres en 49 3 ça révèle la vérité de ce
pouvoir et c'est important aussi pour
les français qu'ils soient au courant de
comment ça fonctionne
c'est à dire ne pas accepter une
opposition qui honnêtement là on en est
on parle de 17 mille amendements mais si
vous divisez par 17 vu que les députés
font une intervention pour chaque 17
amendements identiques
ça fait mille amendements sais rien non
mais vraiment je vous le dis c'est pas
grand chose si on se met accès fait
collectivement que 1000 amendements deux
mille amendements 3000 ha non non c'est
trop pour la démocratie c'est quoi la
suite c'est que sur la prochaine loi où
ils vont casser je ne sais pas
l'assurance chômage pour ça que vous
devez vous me direz ce récap il y en a
pas mal qui l'ont déjà fait mais sur la
prochaine fois ils vont calais où ils
vont casser tel ou tel pan de notre
sécurité sociale ou autre
eh ben il faudrait qu'en d'ekwa 200 sens
et le nombre idéal c'est quoi pour ces 0
c'est ça le nombre idéal pour je vous le
dis et tant qu'ils n'auront pas 0
position parce qu'ils ne tolèrent pas
l'opposition gilet jaune journalistes
dans la rue dans l'assemblée ils ne
tolèrent pas tant qu'ils ont une
opposition ils se comporteront comme ça
donc que le 49-3 la forme le fond pour
moi c'est du blabla
en quelque sorte familièrement j'irai
foutu pour foutu il faut effectivement
mettre le nez sur certaines vérités où
il ya quand même un danger dans cette
stratégie peut être de ne pas en échange
donner d'autres propositions peut-être
sur cet habitant proposions des
retraites
non mais tu chaque chaque groupe
politique a fait des contre-propositions
moi ce que je reproche principalement à
une partie de l'opposition
c'est de vouloir absolument faire durer
ce après les municipales
on sent qu'il ya une volonté aussi par
les médias pas c'est pas je suis
focalisé sur un groupe politique mais on
sent bien que un moment donné moi
j'aurais aimé par exemple que les
chaînes de télé organise des débats sur
la question des retraites qu'on puisse à
un moment donné faire des assemblées
citoyennes
moi je suis un partisan du risque
c'est-à-dire que je pense qu'à un moment
donné il aurait fallu sur ce sujet là
qui est un référent
on a essayé il est groupe parlementaire
de my way ont essayé par exemple sur les
aéroports de paris sur un sujet comme ça
qui est un sujet qui va toucher la vie
quotidienne de millions de français
c'est par un texte ça va être la
dernière réforme du gouvernement macron
il va rester que ça du quinquennat il va
rester le projet de loi sur un pma et la
moralisation de la vie politique ça n'a
pas empêché tous les débats et tous les
excès qui a eu après donc c'est la
dernière réforme que va faire le
gouvernement
donc je pense qu'ils auraient dû prendre
le temps je pense que les députés
auraient dû faire beaucoup de réunions
dans leur circonscription ça a été très
peu le cas et je vous dis encore une
fois moi ce qui me frappe c'est
l'incompétence des députés en marche qui
ne comprennent même pas un texte qui qui
qui sont en train d'examiner
écoutez les réactions écouter dans les
débats ils ne savent même pas répondre à
des questions sur le financement
on en est là aujourd'hui donc il ya un
appauvrissement de la vie politique et
il faut que le parlement se
ressaisissent parce que l'état d'esprit
justement des troupes à l'assemblée
c'est des députés c'est intéressant de
le savoir parce que nous là on en parle
mais justement ce besoin peut-être d'en
vendre en d'en finir parce que ça m'a
l'air compliqué non on est combatif
alors oui il ya de la fatigue humaine
parce que là ils siègent matin midi et
soir du lundi au dimanche mais
n'oublions pas quelque chose dans la
réflexion quand même c'est qu'il ya une
grève il ya des secteurs qui sont en
lutte dans le faut arrêter de se dire
que cette réforme a passé est passée que
c'est fini mais voilà je sais mais je
sais que vous le faites mais moi
j'abandonne pas ce combat là d'accord et
donc le fait de faire durer les
questions en hémicycle et ben dans la
rue ça permet aussi de laisser
l'opportunité d'un second souffle
vous avez un nombre de professions vous
avez déjà la grève la plus longue de la
vème république
nous n'oublions pas je sais que bon les
grappes de cheminots chez la droite
c'est pas leur truc
mais pour moi oui non et donc et donc
c'est un gros lag et vous êtes vous
adapté tous d'accord il revient au galop
mais yahia une grève il ya des avocats
sont % des barreaux de france mobilise
et vous rendez compte c'est celle 10
dans le pays
vous avez des égoutiers qui sont dans la
rue vous avez encore des gilet jaune
vous avez encore des professions les
professeurs donc c'est pas vrai que
comment dire il faudrait se dire allez
c'est foutu la merde elle est foutue
ici le 40e c'est croyez vous encore
débat enfin croyez moi les français
n'aiment pas les labos de se faire
brutaliser de cette nef qui ont retardé
dombasle s'est pas encore fait tourner
en février le 49300 donc s'il ya 48
heures je crois on va compter aussi sur
la mobilisation des français pour
protester je veux dire tout ça c'est un
combat continue il n'y a pas que
l'assemblée ne me faisais pour arriver
au retrait de ce texte peser être dans
le rapport de force donner des arguments
et surtout servir de point d'appui à un
mouvement social où des gens ont fait
grève pendant deux mois ils ont bloqué
le pays ils sont et ils ont un moment de
fatigue notamment les cheminots et les
conducteurs de bus qui c'est vrai de
semaines de mois 200 paye je veux dire
c'est très dur à vivre quand vous avez
des gamins quand vous avez un foyer à
nourrir bon ben voilà c'est ça qui
vivent aujourd'hui mais ceci dit ils
sont ils ont encore la disponibilité
pour se mobiliser et donc le combat
social celui des cheminots celui de
gilet jaune celui des militants
associatifs celui de toutes les
professions qui sont lutte il est encore
d'actualité moi je refuse de me dire que
parraine de 45 3 c'est foutu craignant
d'être là on a parlé de cette réforme et
on parle uniquement des causes moi je
voudrais qu'on parle des conséquences et
l'affaiblissement du parlement s'il n'y
a pas un parlement qui aujourd'hui
représente réellement la france de 2020
c'est parce que le gouvernement et tous
les gouvernements de gauche comme droite
n'ont pas eu le courage de mettre cette
dose de proportionnelle
on a un parlement aujourd'hui qui ne
ressemble pas à la france et c'est là le
principal problème c'est pas une
question 304 députés en marche contre
17,2 la france a soumises ou 104 des
républicains c'est un problème beaucoup
plus grave de représentativité c'est à
dire qu'avec cette ce parlement ils
pourraient voter des mesures on l'a vu
d'ailleurs la loi la loi sus de
l'intérieur où il ya des ya des choses
qui sont très très contestable là le
fond c'est ça c'est que cette majorité
elle peut aujourd'hui tout faire elle
dispose pratiquement des deux tiers donc
c'est le débat sur les retraites
s'ils font 49,3 je vous ai encore dit
tout à l'heure que ni en 93 me en 2003
n'y en 2010 les trois réformes sur les
retraites n'ont jamais été adoptés sur
le 49-3 classe e sera excessivement
grave
on verra dans les jours et semaines qui
viennent ce que va faire le gouvernement
ce qui est cocasse c'est que la loi
macron l'avait été adoptée à l'époque
quand il était ministre de l'économie à
son grand désespoir il trouvé ça pas
très moderne si mes souvenirs sont bons
quand manuel valls a dégainé ce 49 3
c'est un retour à la réalité pour le
président bienvenue dans la réalité de
ce qu'est le le parlement aujourd'hui
mais la réalité c'est qu'il est
minoritaire dans tout le pays c'est ça
la réalité c'est que ils ont cueilli
long que ils ont plus que l'assemblée
nationale c'est à dire une armée de
robots alors qu on reprogramme de temps
en temps pour changer les éléments de
langage mais mais c'est ça la réalité de
la république en marche aujourd'hui ils
vont se prendre une baffe aux
municipales tout le monde le sait sur le
terrain social n'y a plus personne qui
les défend sur les réseaux sociaux
personnes dans l'opinion personne je
veux dire c'est ça et donc c'est pour ça
que je vous dis que moi je
je crois et c'est ce que la france
soumise crois c'est que le combat social
il est encore d'actualité n'oubliez pas
que si le secteur privé se mobilisent i
s'est pas mobilisé encore c'est plus dur
dans le privé de se mobiliser si le
secteur privé se mobilisent une grève
générale de trois jours
c'est pas vrai que le gouvernement il
est fort en trois jours c'est plié je le
dis aux gens qui nous écoutent parce que
ça peut peut-être leur donner des idées
mais en trois jours c'est fini c'est
terminé trois jours de grève générale
ils sont cuits
parce qu'ils ont rien ils ont aucune
assise donc voyez ce qui se passe chaque
fois vous 10 49 3 on est plus fort on
est plus puissant il suffit de quelques
chose qui choque noter aussi les
t-shirts rassembler l'opposition
démocratique et puis surtout il ya des
solutions alternatives
on peut augmenter les salaires pour
financer les retraites on va voir on
peut avoir la retraite à 60 ans c'est
aussi ce qu'on dit à la france soumise
c'est pas juste s'opposer parce que
c'est rigolo de s'opposer c'est que y'a
un modèle une question de modèle de
société la droite a le sien
la france est soumise à l'ancien voilà
c'est ça le la question qui se pose mais
celui d'un marché des objectifs
comptables donc forcément on est content
merci en tout cas tous les deux david
guiraud frédéric latour d'avoir accepté
ce débat on se retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour 1 point que l'on fait sur
l'actuelle
[Musique]
est ce que la chine est la nouvelle
superpuissance du sport tout est
réalisable à la mesure de l'ambition
dévorante de la chine
je pense que dans les années à venir ça
va être un rival important pour être
pour dominer le sport mondial
l'ambition que ce que s'est donnée le
président jean ping s'est non seulement
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
médailles mais d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de chinois qui pratiquent le
sport le football c'est sympathique mans
une des sports les plus connues dans le
monde et la chine veut en faire partie
et votre règne les meilleurs il ya aussi
un petit peu comme en russie une volonté
de nationaliser un peu de sport
indirectement en obligeant les grands
patrons des grandes entreprises qui
appartiennent toutes au parti communiste
à investir ans parlait des plus grandes
fortunes chinoises sont tout
propriétaire d'un club de foot rend chez
l'intéressé de dettes d'abord deux
d'être reconnus d'être reconnu en tant
qu'expert est de faire en sorte que la
chine soit reconnu comme un grand pays
[Musique]
il verra t-on équipements et le cas sera
ma mort seront joints minutes et
wasquehal il prendra ton âme qui est
puis te fais toi qui es tu
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup les pèlerins ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
oh
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de stratégies
peuvent porter des résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
sur les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france qu'est ce qui
pousse tout simplement un apnéiste à
vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles welsh podium c'est
d'arriver à gérer c'est d'arriver à
gérer ses émotions dans un certaine
oriente et c'est un univers qui vous
permet justement d'aller encore plus
loin dans cet état d'introspection et de
travail sur le corps et aussi sur
l'esprit plus on va être dans l'instant
présent et on va être capable de gérer
ce qu'on en a à faire est concentré sur
ce que l'on fait et a conscience et la
capacité à vivre l'instant présent à
être connectés que sur ce qui se passe
sur les sons sur le toucher sur le
ressenti et ça nous pousse dans les
retranchements à changer des choses dans
notre propre vie en dehors de la cne
[Musique]
deux nouveaux cas de coronavirus en
france selon le ministère de la santé
l'épidémie s'étend en europe où plus
d'une trentaine de pays sont désormais
concernés par des patients infectés pour
l' oms le monde est simplement pas prêt
face à une épidémie de goro d'avis rocha
le spectre du 49 3 se rapproche edouard
philippe laisse la porte ouverte à cette
possibilité afin de faire adopter sans
vote le projet de réforme des retraites
le premier ministre qui demandait un peu
plus tôt aux députés la raim de tenir
encore face à l'obstruction de
l'opposition le recours à l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la constitution nécessite le
feu vert du conseil des ministres le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
mahmoud abbas salue l'engagement pour la
cause palestinienne
l'ancien président égyptien hosni
moubarak est décédé aujourd'hui au caire
à l'âge de 91 ans celui qui a présidé le
pays sans partage pendant près de trois
décennies avait dû quitter le pouvoir la
soupe de la révolution égyptienne en
deuxième jour à londres du procès de
julian assange justice britannique
examine depuis hier la demande
américaine d'extradition du fondateur de
wikileaks
sa défense qui aujourd'hui s'est plaint
du traitement qui lui est infligé
washington accuse le lanceur dallaire
d'espionnage assange risque jusqu'à 175
en prison
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si nous nous
rejoignent et en direct sur rt france
est la france seront désormais deux
nouveaux cas confirmés de coronavirus
l'épidémie se propage en europe des cas
confirmés ont été recensés en suisse en
espagne en croatie en autriche épidémie
a fait 11 morts dans le nord de l'italie
et 322 personnes sont contaminées dans
le pays y compris en toscane en ligue
ouvriers en sicile
malgré tout le ministre français de la
santé olivier verront réaffirme sa
volonté de ne pas fermer les frontières
à l'heure actuelle nous souhaitons être
extrêmement clair sur le fait qu'il n'y
a pas lieu de fermer les frontières
entre nos pays ce serait disproportionné
et efi et inefficace à ce stade nous
souhaitons également dire qu'il n'ya pas
lieu d'annuler a priori les grands
événements publics qu'ils soient nature
sportive ou culturelle mais nous nous
accordons la possibilité au cas par cas
de regarder chaque situation en fonction
de l'évaluation que nous aurons de la
part des autorités scientifiques et
sanitaires notamment précéda fermeture
des frontières n'est pas d'actualité
paris invite les français à reporter
leur voyage vers les zones contaminées
d'italie alors comment réagissent les
français la propagation de l'épidémie
écouter ces quelques réactions c'est peu
plus grave qu'une grippe bon
voilà il ya plein d'épidémie troc c'est
pas plus on en parle plus mais c'est pas
beaucoup plus grave
je pense à l'heure actuelle pour
l'instant mon avis il faut pas non plus
voilà l'armé tout le monde et puis faut
prendre des précautions faut être
vigilant mais de la fermer les
frontières non je pense pas qu'il faut
qu'il faille faire ce à quoi mon avis
c'est une bonne décision qu'il a prise
pour l'instant
la situation actuelle dans l'état du
vieux damas l'a dit du virus
je pense que oui il faut fermer cette
frontière qui t'a pas fermer totalement
maîtres mettre des contrôles médicaux
des prises de température et surtout
pendant 14 jours arrêter tous
déplacements en france et plus on en
parle on en parle on en parle foot du
stress on gens on leur fait peur alors
que finalement rien il ya d'autres
choses qui tue beaucoup plus que le
coronavirus quand on voit des on voit
certains sondages où on dit que voilà
c'est 0,2 pour cent des gens qui meurent
un côté d'une grippe ou c'est beaucoup
plus que ça pour quoi [ __ ] la trouille
aux gens l organisation mondiale de la
santé juge très préoccupante
l'augmentation soudaine de nouveaux cas
et ce malgré un d'éclat en chine d'où
est partie l'épidémie et qu'un annoncent
en effet 71 décès supplémentaires soit
le chiffre quotidien le plus bas depuis
plus de deux semaines au total dans le
monde c'est donc une trentaine de pays
qui est touché par le virus
quatre nouveaux territoires du
moyen-orient ont rejoint la liste hier
les personnes concernées revenaient de
l'iran voisin qui a enregistré
officiellement 15 décès le vice ministre
iranien de la santé a lui aussi été
testé positif le récit de françois
tessier bitche en moselle
sur ces images lors d'un point presse
sur le coronavirus le vice-ministre de
la santé iranien iraj archi transpirant
se frotte le front est tous à plusieurs
reprises quelques heures plus tard
l'information est confirmée il est bien
porteur du virus
je voulais vous informer que je suis
positif pour le cours aux navires us
j'ai eu de la fièvre y hier mon test
initial s'est avéré positif tard dans la
soirée
je me suis isolé dans un endroit depuis
hier soir soyez assurés que nous
vaincrons le coronavirus soyez certains
que nous le ferons j'y crois de tout mon
coeur
prenez soin de ce virus est un virus
démocratique
il ne fait pas de distinction entre les
riches et les pauvres ou autres
fonctionnaires et nos fonctionnaires
tout le monde peut la voir lors de cette
conférence ira jarir chier le porte
parole du gouvernement iranien avait
démenti l'affirmation d'un député
selon laquelle 50 personnes auraient
perdu la vie des suites de l'épidémie
dans la ville sainte de qom
d'où le virus est partie en iran le
gouvernement promet la transparence mais
les iraniens reste inquiet j'ai vraiment
peur il n'y a pas de masque dans les
pharmacies le gouvernement devrait
distribuer des masques gratuitement aux
gens s'ils veulent le contenir
nous avons très peur le monde entier
touchées et cela se propage la
télévision d'état nous donne des
statistiques mais quand nous allons à
l'hôpital nous voyons que c'est
différent
le nombre de décès bien plus élevé alors
que le président iranien annonce mardi
que l'iran surmonterait l'épidémie un
membre du parlement vient d'annoncer sur
twitter être également infectée par le
virus mais pour vincent maréchal
professeur à la sorbonne universités
science et cialiste en virologie la
france est plutôt bien préparés pour
faire face aux coronavirus l'information
scientifique a circulé relativement
rapidement alors on peut toujours
discuter sur le retard qui a eus en
chine a à faire part de la situation
il ya une excellente coopération à
l'échelle internationale ça faut que les
gens en aient conscience c'est à dire
que les chercheurs les médecins ne sont
pas isolés dans les différents pays à
une circulation et un partage de
l'information scientifique qui est fait
de façon très
très efficace ce qui a permis à en faire
rapidement très transparent ça c'est
vraiment une mission essentielle
ce qui a permis très rapidement de
développer des tests pour détecter de
façon spécifique les gens qui sont
infectés ce qui veut dire très
rapidement qu'on peut les isoler et donc
ça c'est important lorsqu'on voit
également en france et qu on a eu des
crises précédemment il ya eu la grippe
aviaire pour ceux qui s'en souviennent
il ya eu la grippe h1n1
on a eu un hiver dans le monde
l'épidémie dé sida etc
donc on a on est dans des situations
dans lesquelles on sait que ce risque
infectieux existe on sait que ces
maladies qu'on appelle des maladies
émergentes risquent de revenir avec une
fréquence qui est qui n'est pas
négligeable
on parle de maladies qui pourraient
revenir tous les deux trois ans on est
prévenu on a donc des plans de gestion
sanitaire qui sont relativement efficace
on voit où il fonctionne relativement
bien aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a aussi
une mise en place d'un réseau dans les
hôpitaux qui est qui et prépositionné
qui est peut se développer en fonction
de l'évolution de l'épidémie dont je
pense qu'on est plutôt bien préparé je
suis plus inquiète pour des pays
aujourd'hui qui ne déclaraient pas de
calais s'attendent à ce qu'il en est
edouard philippe demande aux députés de
la majorité de tenir encore face à
l'obstruction de l'opposition sur la
réforme des retraites
le premier ministre est sûre si besoin
il prendra ses responsabilités en
recourant aux 49 3 lorsqu'il faut
prendre ses responsabilités je le fais
sans hésiter et j'utilise tout la
constitution rien que la constitution
mais bien toute la constitution il
appartient monsieur le président à
l'assemblée nationale elle même de faire
vivre ce débat
si ce débat vie et qu'il permet
d'avancer dans de bonnes conditions tant
mieux c'est ce que je souhaite mais à
partir d'un certain moment il faut être
clair nous nous sommes engagés sur ce
système universel de retraite par
répartition et par point et l'engagement
du gouvernement le fait majoritaire
ça existe et en attendant les débats se
poursuivent à l'assemblée pour protester
contre cette réforme il ya d'autres
formes également une marge de 8 jours a
été organisé l etat
aujourd'hui à paris des membres de la
société civile des syndicats des élus de
la france face aux neath notamment
quitté laval en mayenne lundi dernier
des protestations qui est dénonce le
possible recours à 44 ans sont également
notre pays
clairement il vaut mieux qu'ils
réfléchissent à ce qu'ils font parce que
moi je reçois beaucoup de messages
je ne m'imaginais pas que ça aurait un
impact pareil sur la sensibilité du
public beaucoup de gens sont cons
compris qu'il y avait le risque du 49-3
il ya déjà des consignes de
rassemblement autour de l'assemblée
si le 49 3 et décidez donc je pense
qu'il ya où il ya de l'émotion dans le
pays et qu'ils doivent le savoir auprès
de maquereaux et d'edouard philippe ils
doivent se demander alors ce matin nous
a fait un petit numéro à la conférence
des présidents le président de
l'assemblée nous a dit attacher de
prévoir vos procuration pour les deux
tours des élections municipales parce
que vous serez dans l'hémicycle chassant
la ruse et pour francis choisel
historien de la constitution usage du
49-3 n'est pas adaptée à la situation
actuelle
c'est une arme qui n'est pas forcément
du clair mais je trouve que c'est
surtout une norme qui n'est pas adaptée
à la situation
ou du moins pas adapté oui la situation
actuelle c'est à dire que on nous dit
qu'il y a trop d'amendements que le
débat va être trop long il faut
raccourcir le débat mais le 49-3 n'est
pas né n'a jamais été prévu pour
raccourcir un débat le principe du 49 3
c'est que l'origine du 49 3 en 1958
c'était d'éviter la valse des ministères
parce que à chaque fois qu'il y avait un
texte
quand ils étaient rejetés le ministère
le gouvernement se croyait obligé de
démissionner donc on le 43 son objectif
cessé de dire au député attendait c'est
un texte important est ce que
franchement vous voulez renverser le
gouvernement sur ce sujet là qui est un
sujet mineur et donc on leur dit voilà
ici si vous ne disposez pas de motion de
censure le texte passe los dos voyez
c'est pour empêcher que les
gouvernements tombent
presque par hasard des fois parce qu'un
texte mineurs et renverser la ses pattes
l'ex-ministre texte majeur et
conséquence au long de cette réforme des
retraites controversé les cotes de
popularité des manuels micro et
d'edouard philippe sont en baisse celle
du président de la république chute de
trois points et celle de son premier
ministre est en légère baisse également
-1 selon un sondage aux hawks à cgi
publié mardi un français sur trois
considère que le président est un bon
président contre 66 % d'un avis
contraire un avis contraire qui
progresse de +2 points
en france des avocats appellent à une
action collective en justice contre et
ne lis des sociétés chargées de gérer le
réseau d'électricité en france
en cause le compteur linky ce petit
boîtier vers où vous a peut-être
installé chez vous après le lancement
d'une pétition signée par douze mille
personnes ils entendent faire respecter
le droit des consommateurs et veulent
obliger une hélice à ne plus installer
de linky dans les foyers qui n'en
veulent pas mais aussi retiré au besoin
les boîtiers existants et fustige les
pressions qu'exerce selon eux la groupe
sur ses clients et christophe levac s
avocat au barreau de paris nous explique
en quoi cette petite boîte verte pose
problème et comment les consommateurs
organisent leur défense
elle va mesurer aussi le comportement
d'achat que sortent des consommateurs
un identifiant les appareils qui sont
connectés la durée d'utilisation et même
avec la signature qui est laissée par
ces appareils
il va pouvoir déterminer s'ils sont
obsolètes ou new neuf et ça ça va
permettre ensuite en récupérant ces
informations à aînés 10 de les revendre
pour justement permettre à des sociétés
commerciales vous proposer de changer
votre vie et équipements par un nouveau
prêt d'une mise en demeure que nous
avons fait au mois de janvier une
réponse qui nous a pas satisfaite que
nous avons reçu dernièrement nous sommes
obligés de passer par la voie judiciaire
permettre aux consommateurs qui veulent
protéger de voir l'intervention
normalement d'un jugement
martial qui vient de dire année 10
arrêtez vous m'utilise respecter à la
fois la vie privée le domicile privé des
consommateurs est retirée ou n'installez
pas les équipes la mort de l'ancien
président égyptien hosni moubarak il est
décédé au caire à l'âge de 91 ans une
annonce faite par sa famille hosni
moubarak avait dirigé l'egypte pendant
près de trois décennies il avait été
chassé du pouvoir en 2011 par les foules
de la place tahrir au cours de la
révolution égyptienne
lâché par l'armée il a été condamné à la
prison à perpétuité en juin 2012 pour sa
responsabilité dans l'assassinât de
quelques 850 manifestants
il est là finalement été libéré en mars
2010 est très affaibli l'ancien chef de
l'état se trouvait depuis plusieurs
années à l'hôpital militaire gallard du
caire retour en images sur son parcours
[Musique]
non
à
et
[Musique]
les hommages avec celui notamment du
premier ministre palestinien mahmoud
abbas qui salue son engagement pour la
cause palestinienne une émotion partagée
par le premier ministre israélien
benyamin nétanyahou qui salue lui un ami
au nom des citoyens d'israël et au nom
du gouvernement israélien je voudrais
exprimer mon profond regret pour la
disparition du président hosni moubarak
le président moubarak
mon ami personnel était un leader qui a
conduit son peuple à la paix et à la
sécurité à la paix avec israël je les
rencontrais plusieurs fois et j'ai été
impressionné par son engagement et nous
continuerons à suivre cette voie commune
je tiens à adresser mes condoléances au
président el sissi à la famille moubarak
et au peuple égyptien population avons
divisé jusqu'à présent revient avec un
peu d'amertume sur l'image qu'elle
gardera de l'ancien chef de l'état
peut-être que nous les générations des
années 70 et 80 avons grandi avec cet
homme que nous considérons comme un père
il a été au pouvoir pendant plus de
trente ans qu'il repose en paix c'était
un homme respectable et c'est ce que
nous avons vu dans les médias mais ce
n'est pas à nous de juger sa
personnalité
[Musique]
nous avons vécu longtemps sous son règne
ça n'a pas été court comme pour d'autres
présidents et franchement les gens se
sentent mal pour lui
ma famille se sent mal nous lui
souhaitons miséricorde et pardon qu'il
repose en paix c'était un homme
respectable et nous avons été témoin de
beaucoup de bonnes choses en son temps
mais il a subi beaucoup d'injustices
dans ce pays
c'était une grande injustice mais
qu'allons nous dire qu'il repose en paix
et pour eux ahmad youssef romancier
journaliste et universitaire égyptien
hosni moubarak et le président qui a
permis à l'egypte d'obtenir une
stabilité depuis ces trente dernières
années
c'est sur la personnalité et de moubarak
dont qui se sont donc mis tous les deux
d'accord je crois que ils ont compris
mahmoud abbas le président abbas et le
premier ministre israélien que moubarak
était une soupape de sucre sécurité dans
la région
il a comme vous vous souvenez
certainement que les conférences de paix
qu'il a organisée à charm-el-cheikh
plusieurs conférences notamment la
présence de quelques chefs detat
français européens et américains donc il
a un vrai pendant 30 ans pour la
question pour la paix disons je vais pas
dire seulement la question palestinienne
peu mais pour la paix au moyen-orient à
cpc il avait une vision assurant la paix
au moyen orient
si vous allez dans les cas des
extrémistes c'est ça le vrai son comble
mais si vous allez dans la rue arabe en
général et bien elles sont pas contre
son action pour le pays
dormann orient
julian assange saura-t-il extradé vers
les états unis deuxième jour de procès
pour le fondateur de wikileaks il
comparaît depuis hier devant la justice
britannique londres doit décider de
donner suite ou non la demande
américaine d'extradition du lanceur
d'alerté australiens ont fait le point à
londres avec notre reporter bcm chili
c'était une deuxième journée d'audience
pour julian assange dans ce procès hors
norme du lanceur d'alert qui a été placé
en détention depuis avril dernier après
avoir passé sept ans dans l'ambassade
équatorienne à londres deuxième jour
d'audience hier c'était les américains
qui ont plaidé ils ont revenu sûr c'est
que reprochés à julian assange à savoir
la publication en 2010 de documents
classés top secret d'avoir mis en danger
la vie de témoins et la vie d'individus
18 chefs d'accusation contre lui
aujourd'hui c'était les juges d'avocats
de julian assange qui ont pu s'exprimer
ils sont revenus sur les conditions de
détention de julian assange sur ce que
reprochent les américains à junas anges
ils sont contre cette extradition ils
ont dit qu'une extradition serait aller
à l'encontre de la liberté de la presse
la liberté d'expression et la liberté de
julian assange vous propose d'écouter le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks ainsi que
le père de julian assange
nous sommes dans le contexte d'un empire
abusifs qui ripostent et qui veut se
venger sur une base politique pour faire
un exemple de julian assange pour faire
un exemple de lui pour effrayer les
autres journalistes qui veulent faire
leur travail en particulier ceux qui
s'intéressent aux problèmes de sécurité
tout ce procès auquel nous assistons
n'est compréhensible que si on prend en
compte la présence de forces obscures
qui tentent d'étouffer et de faire taire
ceux qui veulent mettre en lumière les
actions néfastes de cet empire ce mal
qui émane des services persécuteurs
s'est étendue sur dix ans cela fait
maintenant dix ans que julien des
prisonniers
dix ans de détention arbitraire de
trahison et de tensions il y à la
torture psychologique aussi ces deux
faits ont été documentés par le
rapporteur des nations unies sur la
torture et le groupe de travail des
nations unies sur la détention
arbitraire
je ne comprends pas pourquoi julien est
en prison
absolument je pense que tout compte fait
c'est un procès politique est une perte
de temps pour le tribunal les avocats de
julian assange sont revenus sur les
allégations portées par les américains
sur ce dossier il ont déclaré que julian
assange ne faisait que son travail son
travail de journaliste et répondent à
ses négations et répondre favorablement
à une extradition vers les états unis
serait une régression dans la démocratie
une violation de la liberté de la presse
est une violation de la liberté
d'exercer le métier de journaliste si ce
revenu sur les différents points
développés par les américains ils ont
parlé de mensonges ils ont ils également
déclaré que l'organe américain avait
publié certains documents qu'on reproche
à wikileaks d'avoir développé le dow
jones continuera bien sûr jusqu'à
vendredi et si la cour londonienne
accède cette extradition
jonathan je pourrais en cours et jusqu'à
175 ans de réclusion et pour guillaume
ledit auteur de dans la tête de julian
assange ce procès est une manière
indirecte de faire taire les
journalistes à partir du moment où
l'administration trump a décidé de
poursuivre le travail de chasse aux
lanceurs d'alerté mis en place par
l'administration obama et les
administrations précédentes
il apparaît assez clair que la volonté
du gouvernement des états unis et de
faire taire les lanceurs d'alerté dans
un premier temps et les journalistes
dans un deuxième temps ce qui est à
particulier avec avec ses audience
d'extradition c'est que julian assange
et s'il est extradé sera poursuivie aux
états unis au titre de l'espionage act
d'espionnage actes comme son nom
l'indiqué est un texte qui date de 1917
et qui a pour vocation à poursuivre les
espions les ennemis
états unis qui agissent à
l'international c'est la première fois
qu'un homme est poursuivi pour un
travail journalistique
au titre de cet espionnage actes car
julian assange comme vous le savez n'est
pas un simple lanceur d alerte c'est
également un homme qui a facilité donc
les des lanceurs d alerte les
publications document et qui a effectué
pour ce qui lui est reproché là dans le
cadre de ce procès un véritable le
travail journalistique fonds souverain
d'abou dhabi mubadala investir un
milliard d'euros en france annonce du
ministre français de l'économie et des
finances
cet argent sera injectée au fonds
d'investissement pour les grandes
entreprises françaises cotées voulue par
emmanuel macron un fonds placés sous
l'autorité de la banque d'investissement
française bébé pays france en visite
dans la capitale émirati bruno le maire
s'est réjoui de cette transaction
c'est un jour historique pour la
relation entre la france et les émirats
arabes unis vous savez que la france a
décidé de créer sous l'autorité de la
banque publique d'investissement un
fonds d'investissement la vocation de ce
fonds d'investissement
c'est de garantir un actionnariat stable
et un actionnariat de long terme pour
les plus grandes entreprises françaises
pour les entreprises cotées
la vocation de ce fonds c'est une
vocation de stabilité et de
développement pour les plus grandes
entreprises françaises
le premier fonds souverains étrangers
qui va investir dans ce fonds
d'investissement français c'est le fonds
d'abou dhabi le fonds abu dallas dirigé
par khalil douna le moubarak un ami que
j'ai l'occasion de voir fréquemment avec
lequel nous avons beaucoup travaillé
depuis plusieurs mois avec également le
directeur général de la banque publique
d'investissement nicolas dufourcq qui
est à abou dhabi aussi aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est un signal très fort
d'avoir le fonds souverain d'abou dhabi
qui investit un milliard d'euros dans ce
fonds d'investissement à la française
très pour younes belle fellah économiste
et spécialiste du monde arabe
cet investissement fait suite à deux
plusieurs autres contrats passés entre
les deux pays
le milliard qui est investi par les
emiriens c'est pour des secteurs qui
un grand potentiel donc on parle de
l'énergie énergies renouvelables on
parle des start up et des nouvelles des
nouvelles technologies donc ça permet
pour la france d'avoir un nouveau
partenaire
mais c'est passait pas le premier
partenariat avec avec les émirats parce
qu'il ya des grands projets qui sont
très intéressants notamment le projet de
eads sur le développement des satellites
avec 1,6 milliard de dollars et à
l'autre projet également astrum ratp ou
un milliard de dollars pour le
développement des métros et des tramways
à dubaï et à abou dhabi et troisièmement
aussi un autre projet qui le projet de
total avec un grand un grand partenariat
destiné à exporter 7% de l'électricité
dans le monde
concrètement on parle d'un pays comme
les émirats arabes unis une économie
émergente et parmi les 30 premières
économies dans le monde avec un pib qui
avoisine 400 milliards de dollars et il
ya encore plusieurs je dirais
opportunités d'affaires qui sont qui
peuvent être concrétisées par la suite
entre paris et abu dhabi
oui c'est la fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi prochain rendez-vous
demain matin 7 heures du matin heure
française en direct vers et france
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]